[Laughter]
hey here we are we're live yeah
it's saturday night instead of friday
night still wiped out from last night
actually kind of really i am i'm tired
you slept a lot longer than i did though
i'm just tired i woke up at
seven or quarter to eight yeah because
my stomach hurt so i had to get up and i
couldn't go back to sleep
so it was too hot in the room why'd your
stomach hurt i don't know and it was too
hot in there yeah it's always too hot in
there yeah as soon as like the sun comes
up i'm always kind of like i can't
really be in the room anymore because
it's too warm but you said that at 71.
now it's 73 i know so it could be 60 and
you'd probably think it was too hot
well i don't know about that but it's
usually too hot in there for me i don't
know why
yeah it seems normal to me it's not yeah
it's actually cold in the in this office
usually but
so
we um went to the show last night it's
pretty good
saw uh gino's jezebel
saw this uh
bam from goth band from texas called uh
wrote uh was it rose garden general
party party yeah had this
girl who was singing i was talking to
her she wants to do business with when
it comes to graphics it sounded good
they kind of sound like skeletal
skeletal family
if you guys ever heard of that they're
from scotland i think right skeletal
family
uh yeah i think so
kind of sound like that aren't they
scottish skeletal family dj mania
probably knows yeah
dj maniac just said not hanging out late
tonight got a goth thing to do in the
city
yeah we did our goth thing last night
was a good turnout
it was actually four bands that were
playing i thought it was just the two
but yeah they had um
sandman sleeps and then they had like
another band that was local
yeah and i can't remember what they were
called i really was really really only
into two of them but
rose guard funeral in [ __ ]
genome jezebel yeah rose garden funeral
party were really now
um gene loves jezebel only had two
people in the band this time it was good
though
most of it was electronics on the poster
i think there's three or four guys
because i think they that jay said
something about uh normally they would
be there'd be more there'd be three or
four of them in the band but they
couldn't
some of them couldn't come to some dates
for whatever reason yeah so i guess
that's why yeah so it was really it was
just two guys it was like a jam session
yeah it was kind of played some old
stuff [ __ ] sang [ __ ]
the cow
[ __ ] yeah desire always a flame
always a flame motion of love yeah
emotion of love yeah but then he did
some other ones that i didn't know yeah
they were good they're okay he sounds
exactly the same that's exactly the same
i wonder how old he is i don't know 60
maybe he's got to be as close we talked
to him a little bit after yeah he's
because he hung around he was like yeah
he was super nice he's funny
yeah i didn't realize because i'd never
seen them live before but it's like yeah
he was cracking jokes like all this all
the [ __ ] time he was like pretty
[ __ ] funny yeah some of the other
bands are playing and he's he's [ __ ]
back in the little back room where the
merch was [ __ ] looking at his [ __ ]
phone like that with his little hat
he looks like something [ __ ]
feels the nephilim yeah
he did look a little bit late
how you doing mr aston [ __ ] nice to
meet you it's like a nug i i got here
out i got the first albums [ __ ] uh
immigrant and discover i got it when
they came out man i grew up with your
[ __ ] music he says i want to thank
you for your work he's like oh thank you
he's friendly you know
good he goes uh
you know hopefully it's going to be a
good show i don't mean i hope i don't
disappoint you this is no i'm just i'm
just here to see you thank you you know
that kind of stuff and then yeah he
seemed really yeah and after the show we
were [ __ ] talking to him and stuff
he's pretty cool a lot of people [ __ ]
a lot of old gurus had to talk to him
about music i guess you know
which probably bores him but you know he
doesn't i talk to him a little bit about
whales because yeah because yeah because
that the band is welsh and i was like oh
i knew her that yeah yeah he's from
where i'm from yeah well i knew that's
why i asked him about it he said he was
from port call and i was like oh i've
been there i think he was like kind of
surprised about that i went i actually
went to fourth call one time
because my ex-mother-in-law was friends
with steve strange's mom and steve
strange's mom lived in port call and we
went there to visit her
i can't remember which i'm sure she's
probably dead now well steve strange is
dead too isn't he yeah i think he died
kind of young i have his uh
autobiography blitzed which is actually
really good oh bless you sweetheart a
lot of people have no idea what we're
talking about
what else is there yeah
[Laughter]
so let's see how many people are in now
okay yeah they're all starting to come
in
um
dj's media maniacs hasn't gone over 70
today in new york lucky yeah
yeah maniac said he saw rose garden
funeral party it's great yeah they're
good they're really good i think that
was the first time i'd seen them
was it maybe i thought they were at
absolution last year but maybe they were
um maybe they performed on a day that we
weren't there because absolution was
three days and we only went the one day
that a starry night were there so they
must not have been the same he said an
elephant murdered woman then showed up
to her birthday for her funeral to make
sure she's dead can we talk about that
elephant that murder woman and then
showed up at her funeral to make sure
i never heard of that what are you
talking about
maybe something like that happened is it
some new meme or something
i heard the craziest [ __ ]
today oh [ __ ] it's like in the news
in england
an entire parachute
battalion
[ __ ] a a [ __ ] british airborne
battalion
got caught
they snuck a woman into the barracks and
they were having big orgy with her just
one woman a whole battalion again i
don't know how this happened the video
has got to be out there so i mean was
she like a willing participant yeah or
oh yeah yeah
and they uh more power too many videos
of it
and yeah i'll take y'all on yeah
and to punish the battalion they
wouldn't let them go on the [ __ ]
kosovo mission
kosovo training mission which just i'm
just like what what the [ __ ] are they
talking about
i don't know what the [ __ ] going on in
england man we are our our military's
[ __ ] up too okay
you punish a unit by denying it training
[ __ ] in charge of that place well it's
just it's almost just kind of like when
you [ __ ] up at school and they're like
and they suspend you
stay home and play video games okay yeah
like what the [ __ ] are they talking
about first of all my day they never
would have punished us for something
like that they just would have waited
good job
you guys are all porn stars aha you know
they just sort of laughed it off you
know
but then
man if they tried to punish us they
would go no okay instead of [ __ ]
denying you the kosovo trading mission
we're going to send you three times in a
row
[ __ ] you're gonna be out there for 18
months you stupid [ __ ] you gotta need
retraining you know they just increase
training not decrease it i've never
heard of [ __ ] any [ __ ] like that
because
you'd just be [ __ ] up to get in
trouble to get out of training
well yeah that's that's what you just
continue to [ __ ] up
no so i don't understand that
somebody in england can
can explain that to me
slasher fred says one of these days you
should watch and review the 1993 horror
comedy movie my boyfriend's back yeah i
remember seeing that i remember that
being like uh pretty funny we should
actually get around to that you know
what's interesting i actually got to add
some different movies to the patreon
poll this weekend because
i discovered that you remember when i
had to up my phone plan
uh to you know because we had to like
stream from the phone a couple times
like as a mobile hotspot
when i upgraded my phone plan
they gave me hbo max for free
so
now i have hbo max which means in the on
the xbox we can download the app and we
can like watch the movies and [ __ ] on
there and i looked on there the other
day and they have a [ __ ] ton of stuff
they have a bunch of like uh horror
stuff that isn't on other streaming
services which is nice so it's a
streaming service you watch it yeah you
want to see it not when they touch it
yeah it's not like old hbo no nothing's
like that anymore that would suck you're
like no thanks even the free [ __ ] like
pluto and stuff you can either
watch live tv or you can go over and
just watch whatever the [ __ ] you want
like you know what i mean like on demand
no they're saying it was all on the news
that this elephant killed some chick and
then showed up at her theater to make
sure she was dead and they said that the
[ __ ] elephant was keeping it real
what did she do to the elephant
i don't know anything about it
did she maybe have like an umbrella
stand that was made out of like the
elephant's dad's foot or something
you remember those umbrella stands like
that i feel like that was like was that
like a victorian thing yeah that's
[ __ ] up why would you want that
they didn't want to waste any part of
the elephant they turned everything into
some kind of a [ __ ] um what do you
call it leave the elephants alone turn
into some kind of uh
souvenir
yeah but the elephant they should step
on more people yeah
clearly some people need it
[Laughter]
they should like [ __ ] rampage more
all those circumstances
they are that's what i'm saying elephant
probably knew that she was
dead it's just covered i didn't know
when i came to pay my respects you know
what dead things are they go and pick up
bones of dead relatives
they'll have dead relatives out in a
certain graveyard they'll put them where
they die yeah they have elephant
graveyards they're pretty they're like i
said they're really really they'll go
down there to die
and then they go out there [ __ ]
on their way to the water holes and
visit the dead
which is kind of weird they get kind of
[ __ ]
they say they act kind of spooky
yeah like they're returning like
lamenting yeah
they're like but they know that it's
that's betty and they know who it is
yeah
that's a that's yeah i've heard of that
before it didn't didn't we watch some
video like a while back of some people
and they got like their car their jeep
or something like was like stuck in a
mud hole and an elephant came and like
helped them get it out
yeah they do stuff like that
she's like hey you guys need some help
it's like what's helping him like push
it out of the [ __ ] box people help
get their children out of mud holes and
stuff yeah that's like that's pretty
funny yeah
um
let's see what is that
murder hornet return says in boot camp
uh we was in boot camp in formation and
heard a girl screaming the company
behind us the drill sergeant yelled out
shut the [ __ ] up coming to find out she
was being raped that's nice i don't
believe that
why not where was this
yeah shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up
and get raped yeah thanks
thanks
he must not have known about it
well obviously i mean i would hope not
or he's like the most careless some
[ __ ] ever
holy [ __ ]
uh let's see
slasher fred said there was a tv series
i remember watching uh called when
animals attack oh yeah i remember that
one i remember that one wasn't that that
was just on like a regular
uh like network tv i thought
one of those kind of [ __ ]
didn't that have that one where that kid
like fell into the gorilla
cage or yeah they shot the gorilla
yeah
his name was harabe
that's right i remember he's pulling the
kid around
i don't know if he would hurt the kid
though
they just they just couldn't take the
chance i guess not it didn't look like
he was going to hurt him but no he just
couldn't figure out what to do with him
yeah he's like what's this thing in here
did you guys lose this although gorillas
are [ __ ] too even though they're
they're more chilled out than champs
they had a damn domestic cat that fell
into them with the thing with the
gorillas
and that grill just picked it up by the
base of the tail and looked it through
it
yeah they were like disgusted they
didn't want to touch it but they kept
running up and throwing it
it finally
um people called
told the the zoo people that there was a
cat in there and they
hit the siren and then
opened up the gates you know feeding
time and they all the gorillas ran in
ran indoors like [ __ ] it yeah let's go
inside
and uh the cat was underneath the log
and an artificial log that they had
there and the girls went down there and
got it brought it out cat was [ __ ]
terrified well yeah cat rat right cat
ran right to two people but help yeah
but right away from the [ __ ] gorillas
yeah i don't like these big hairy people
yeah they trapped it in a corner you can
see it on youtube no thank you
i'm not gonna watch gorilla versus cat
there's one on there they trapped it in
the corner and it's sitting there trying
to
get as small as it possibly can and they
walk up pick it up
[ __ ] throw it
oh no they were like they were treating
it like it was a mouse or a rat
something dirty you know like yeah maybe
that's what they thought it was because
it was little yeah what was the size it
was bigger than pooky about the size of
spooky
kevin's trying to play dead
you know oh man
see at least they can't do that to
pookie because she doesn't have a tail
yeah plus i'm not taking her to a zoo or
anything like that well just you hear me
pokey yeah they only just walk in
yeah domestic animals and shit'll just
walk in yeah i guess so it was walking
it was walking across the uh
the wall that separated the uh the
guerrilla event to another event so it's
walking across the top
oh okay and it came down
it came down in the habitat
see what's going on down here oh no yeah
i've made it terrible i have a few i
have a feeling the gorillas weren't in
the habitat when it came down yeah maybe
not and then they let the gorillas out
and then they [ __ ] the camera what is
that little thing yeah
no they just saw it in there like what
the [ __ ] is that
but they were um those same gorillas
were um
uh throwing raccoons around they killed
the
raccoon a couple of them this is
gorillas were just dicks
they just killed anything that was in
the habitat when they came in raccoons
would make their way in there
people in the people in the audience
catch it on with their phones
that's [ __ ] up yeah maybe they were
just jerks because they didn't like
being in captivity or maybe those were
just like [ __ ] gorillas in general no
i just think that
gorillas know that things aren't
supposed to be in their habitat in there
well remember that one remember that one
gorilla coco that had a pet kitten yeah
all ball
that was also uh that was also a mix
they were just killing anything that was
in there
yeah yeah if it was in there they'd kill
it that's [ __ ] up or tried to that's
[ __ ] up throwing it around
so i guess that's why they had to end up
like killing uh harambe or whatever
about that yeah
although like i said it didn't look like
he was gonna hurt the kid but i guess
like you said you can't really take the
chance that's just like really shitty
that was a shitty situation
look he was playing with the kid
yeah pulling it across the water
[Laughter]
he's looking
it's looking in the kids clothes what is
this thing
what is the stuff that you're wearing
yeah
why aren't you naked it was a person
they see people
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
john gore said i used to have an awesome
original creep show one sheet
uh with the with that bernie writes in
art i traded it in high school for a
pack of smokes sadly don't you wish you
had that back
you know what they had when we were in
fye the other day where i got this shirt
they actually had
um
like that book that they put out
uh when creep show came out that was
like the comic that had all of the
stories in it and i kind of wanted it
but i was like 30 bucks and i was like
well i can't really afford that but it
was like it was so so pretty
okay i said look up youtube rat terrier
where they have these small dogs that
will catch rats and shake them to death
yeah that's right i've heard about that
that's what they bred them to do that
didn't it
like to go catch rats and [ __ ] like that
that's [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up
all right so
needs re tom needs to really like
perk up a little bit you need some kind
of you need some caffeine or something
no alcohol
you need alcohol yeah
you drank quite a bit last night yeah
i make a
comeback a comeback yeah it's going to
take time i almost i stuck till i was
trying to stick to like low calorie last
night i just drank some [ __ ] white
claws yeah i didn't even get any hard
liquor yeah and then plus they were
cheaper too and they're and they're only
100 calories per can i still spend 100
bucks last night did you really yeah i
only spent 25 between gas and everything
else spent about a hundred
and then we stopped that yeah and then
we stopped at circle k
got walkway
because i was like i don't i don't
really want it it's like three o'clock
in the morning i don't want to deal with
microbes come on three they want three
dollars for those [ __ ] when i was a
kid they were 99 cents they want three
dollars for them i think some places
they're still 99 cents or they used to
be not too long ago yeah and then they
had then they had uh they had like a
mcrib sandwich in there microwaved it
good it was good i [ __ ] it was it
rolled up in a paper uh sack type of
thing and then and the burrito was in a
plastic bag
i just ripped the end of the plastic bag
and [ __ ] kept the [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
plastic sack they gave you know the
carry sack yeah i threw the whole thing
in the microwave
did you really
yeah three minutes to do it out there
put three minutes on it
came back in that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
piping hot too hot
i had to unwrap the [ __ ]
rib sandwich
and let it air out
she was [ __ ] sweaty
that's a sweaty and sweaty eel it dried
out though
the thing is
it didn't have any barbecue sauce on it
i should have put i have a [ __ ] on a
barbecue sauce i should have put
barbecue sauce on it and pickles
well yeah i mean you know i wasn't
thinking it is just like a circle k yes
i mean the thing about it is it was as
good as a mcdonald's [ __ ] big rib but
it didn't have any sauce on it yeah
it would have been the same they had
sauce it's funny because and we've
talked about this before i kind of feel
like convenience store food used to be
like roll bottom of the barrel
but even the
rural circle k but actually we have two
circle k's like they're they're right
across the street from each other it's
like a new york starbucks situation that
way you don't have to make a u-turn yeah
you could just like that one come on
now the one on our side is a little bit
bigger and it has a subway in it but
what the other one is like you know but
yeah so we you go in there and
they had like all kind of nice looking
say i was gonna get a cuban sandwich
and then i was like thinking about it
and i was like well that looks kind of
big and also it was like six bucks and i
was like i don't think i can eat all
that so i ended up just getting like a
little bitty like i think it was chicken
and cranberry or something like that so
i got one of those and that was actually
that was not too bad although
maybe
it did it tasted fine but then like this
morning i had like a really bad
stomachache so i was like i wonder if i
got food poisoning but maybe not maybe
it wasn't that i don't think it was that
nope because it tasted like totally yeah
food
food poisoning you'd be throwing up
yeah that's what i thought yeah i was
just kind of like man must have just
been maybe it was just all the
carbonation from the white claw or
whatever i don't know what the [ __ ] it
was i don't know what the [ __ ] it was
slasher fred said there is a 90s tv
horror movie called strays
that is like the birds except it has
cats i heard about that but i don't
think i've ever seen it it's almost kind
of like
didn't we do
that stephen king that was a stephen
king adaptation right sleepwalkers
and it wasn't really about like the
the people were what the [ __ ] were they
werewolves vampire i don't remember the
planet ever it was a dumb movie but um
they were like really really scared of
cats so they always had all the cats
like sitting on their lawn
and remember there was that one scene
where there was like all the dead cats
like hanging from trees and [ __ ] like
that and i was just like traumatized
they were like were cats weren't they
yeah or something wear something i guess
they were supposed to be wear cats then
why are they scared of cats you'd think
the cats would be like their brethren or
whatever or wear bats or wear rats or
something it was dumb
it was dumb it was dumb it was
wasn't there one with dogs called the
pack yeah i think there's probably been
more than one i would imagine yeah danny
rowling said they were shape-shifting
cat humanoids yeah
so maybe yeah maybe they didn't like
cats because cats were like competition
the cats were calling and calling them
out yeah what about being figs
[Laughter]
[Music]
you guys are peoples you can't be you
can't be kool-aid cats yeah
i'm like that
[Laughter]
yeah camp guys talking about how good
cuban sandwiches are yeah i was like
that's kind of why when i was in there
like looking at all the sandwiches they
had i was like ooh i haven't had a cuban
sandwich in a long time
yeah that's stuff that they have a
circle okay it doesn't sit there for
long
it's you know i mean those sandwiches i
think i think they're they're they're i
think they can only be there for like
[ __ ] 48 hours and they're
refrigerated
so they're okay
and um
if you look at them [ __ ] they they go
like hotcakes
well yeah it could sell out fast i kind
of feel like working
yeah because there's a lot of like farm
workers and stuff like that around here
so there's always like people stopping
there like getting sandwiches and donuts
yeah [ __ ] like that
in the morning you know what i don't
think they have i don't know i haven't
really looked around too much in there i
don't think they have like the big
like coffee bar kind of situation like
they have in 7-eleven i was looking in
there though man they had breakfast
sandwiches and i'm like okay yeah [ __ ]
mcdonald's
i'll just stop here and honestly the
7-eleven i used to get breakfast
sandwiches sometimes at the 7-eleven
that was by my work and those were
actually really really good you could
get two for five dollars like especially
the one that was like a that was like a
um like eggs and sausage like on a
croissant oh that [ __ ] was delicious
they had them and most of them were gone
yeah there was like only one one or two
left
i was like i almost almost got one of
those but then that mcrib started
calling me you know i don't get the i
don't get the appeal of the mcrib the
mcdonald's one i think it's and you know
maybe it's just i know everybody has
different taste buds and stuff but i'm
always i think i've maybe had one or two
my entire i'm not a big barbecue sauce
person anyway but
i think it's mostly because it's limited
time so everybody like gets all jacked
like when it's out because it's not
really all that good it's not i mean
it's not bad it's just not really all
that special you know what i mean
oh brian hit brian say what's up brian
hey what's up yeah what's up
i just kind of feel like i don't know
like mcdonald's having that and then
like the shamrock shake yeah oh yeah
because it's limited
what what flavor is the shamrock shake
supposed to be is it mint is it mint
yeah
it's good i love mint stuff but i was
always kind of like weirdly grossed out
by the shamrock shake i don't know why
you'd think that i would love that kind
of stuff cause mint chocolate chip is
one of my favorite ice cream flavors
murder
murder hornet says mexico has a ripoff
7-eleven it has the same logo and
everything it's called seven select nice
yeah
i've seen that i've seen that one seven
select i've seen it i thought it was
7-eleven i thought it was just a mexican
7-eleven
but it's it's a rip-off it's not owned
by the same company i thought it was
owned by the same company like a license
i thought it was the same same company
just
a mexican
rendition of it but i may be wrong
because i've seen it it looks like a
7-eleven exactly
everybody talks about how fancy the
7-elevens are in japan yeah you can pay
your taxes there you can do like
everything you can get married at
7-eleven yeah you can like hang out in
there there's one like
yeah
it's like a whole big thing and like all
they have sushi they have like all this
really really super good food and yeah
well you had a different path of
evolution in japan yeah it's not like
it's not what it is to us to us it's
just a damn dime store
i mean and the thing about it is that in
japan that is actually the definition of
convenience store that is convenient you
can get everything [ __ ] thing in
there [ __ ] man do they have like a
tailor you get your clothes tailored you
can't know i'm just making that going
get your dry cleaning
rubbed down and happy
you can get everything at 7-eleven
everything get your car detailed you
know what i mean just roll it on in here
uh brian uh brian asked tom and jenny
have you seen mad god on shutter now
i haven't watched it yet but yeah you're
like the second or third person that's
recommended that's good um yeah it looks
super cool that was like one of the ones
that um that i wanted to watch it's
isn't it it's stop motion animation i
think i don't know it just saw i just
saw a poster for it yeah i think it's
stop motion animation if i'm not uh if
i'm not mistaken but yeah you're the
second or third person that has
recommended that so we'll definitely
maybe yeah maybe we can watch it tonight
we um for the matinee show tomorrow
we'll probably talk about the last duel
because dermot uh
or one of our patrons like uh sent me
money to buy it so i bought it we
watched it it was great not last night
but the night before yeah so we'll talk
about that tomorrow but yeah so we can
watch mad god tonight and talk about
that on monday maybe
um
camp guy said like the whole damn store
is vending machines
where in japan yeah yeah where you can
get a lot of wild stuff
yeah
yeah maybe
it just looked it looked like a nice
store to me and with grocery store and a
[ __ ] hotel in the back
it's got [ __ ] booths and [ __ ] you can
go in the back and a daycare center
it did
i was like you could just move in yeah
yeah a little [ __ ] you could random a
little sleeping tight little sleeping
[ __ ]
little tubes little cubby yeah
but you know it
it's a pretty rural a pretty excuse me
pretty urban environment in in japan so
i guess it they're they're essentially
located no matter where you are there's
one around there
so they
try to offer everything you
know so it makes sense there you
couldn't do that here
you'd lose your ass
although i have to say that especially
like in the last decade or so i've often
been surprised at what stuff you can get
at a 7-eleven like yeah you wouldn't
think that yeah or stuff there that you
would be hard to get yeah like like
sometimes i was like oh my god they have
like empty gas cans and they have like
they have like all kind of stuff that i
wasn't like experiencing them yeah your
oil changed
[Laughter]
battery yeah not quite
maybe in the japan one yeah but you know
uh danny rowling said nowadays you got
fast food workers peeing in the
milkshake machines no thank you on that
do they really why would you go to all
the trouble of peeing in the milkshake
machine anything can happen anywhere
well you gotta be careful where you are
i'm not too worried about it that's
probably some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up areas i mean some of these
cities are just [ __ ] up
yeah
brian says sometimes the pizzas are good
at 7-eleven yeah i don't know if i've
ever had
oh no i have i i was gonna say i don't i
don't think i've ever bought a 7-eleven
pizza but i think like somebody went
over like where i worked one time and
got one and it was gave me a piece and
it was actually pretty good
but some of their other [ __ ] like i used
to go over there all the time and get
they had breakfast sandwiches they had
like just regular you know lunch
sandwiches they had um little
like cheese and nut
plates like little trays that you could
have for breakfast and like with little
dried fruit and stuff like that so they
had all kind of [ __ ] like that
the way cities are evolving is a trip
especially around here
i mean a lot of the clubs left from the
downtown or the clubs that we went to
left from downtown
and they're all moving out into the
suburbs
and uh they're building downtown
and they'll [ __ ] they threw up a huge
building just in the time that me and
jenny weren't there for like a couple
like a couple bucks
like i don't remember that [ __ ]
building it's a [ __ ]
eight nine story building and then you
come up on it and it's a it was a
parking structure
look at a huge [ __ ] skyscraper just
out of nowhere
i mean it hasn't been that way well
when was the last time well last time we
went down there was memento mori but we
didn't go on i-4 though did we uh no we
just took uh the toll road right we
haven't been down our obt we hadn't
taken that road in about a month or so
yeah so we haven't been on uh on i-4
last night we had to go on i-4 for but
only for like 10 minutes or something
for like four miles huge ass building
just appeared out of nowhere
yeah that was crazy i was like wait yeah
that looks that i don't really remember
that thing
it was like eight nine stories big there
was a huge parking garage
yeah it was like and it was had like a
this big glass front i'm like yeah crap
yeah
it was a parking garage
that was uh
camouflaged to look like a
you
skyscraper
you get up on it you say oh okay that's
a parking garage
but it at first glance it looks like a
glass skyscraper
yeah it was great and it makes you
wonder like what are they building all
that [ __ ] for i thought everybody's
working from home you know this online
stuff
but i guess they're
i guess there are people that live
downtown still in that area
it's apartment complexes huh
yeah probably there's probably a lot of
apartment complexes around there maybe
there's not enough parking for everybody
i would imagine
is there work downtown though
i don't know yeah i don't know if
there's any work it's just
we don't know how any of this [ __ ] works
anymore i imagine a lot of people don't
know how this [ __ ] works anymore i mean
we sound like old people like i don't
know anything works anymore
because
[Laughter]
there used to be
rest there's restaurants down there yeah
there's lots of restaurants actually
they're still there actually a lot of
them they've opened some new news a lot
it's it's just
the only thing that's really downtown in
orlando that has to do with
jobs per se would be banks lots of
[ __ ] banks yeah there's big banks and
they're just bank buildings and i think
they're mostly empty
well no because you can rent out office
space in there so a lot of other
businesses probably have office spaces
in there too it's not just all the bank
offices because they don't need all that
[ __ ] room yeah i wouldn't think so
either they make up they make a lot of
their money by renting office space out
to like other companies you could put a
bank on a phone now
i'm sure a cell phone could run a
[ __ ] multi-fucking billion dollar
transnational bank you could probably
just run it because it's all electronic
so i imagine a phone is probably
powerful enough to run the whole
operation
murder uh murder hornet says how old is
the oldest goth you know at the club
ooh
50s
mid 50s late 50s yeah they start aging
out they just stop showing up a lot but
we the ones that still come out we know
some that are at least 55 56 something
like that yeah maybe there's a couple
that are older but i can't remember they
had some show up last night to the show
and you know they're old gods but they
don't they're not dressing it anymore
but they know the [ __ ] music and
they all they're all family people now
yeah they they look like family people
look at somebody's mom and dad yeah
that's exactly what they look like which
is funny they had one dude who you know
he was probably about five years older
than me and he was jacked he was on the
sauce
and uh he was looking good man and
[ __ ] with his bauhaus t-shirt on and
[ __ ] oh yeah i saw that guy yeah
yeah he's just old goth guy yeah you
know
uh but haven't seen that dude at the
club he just showed up for the show
well that seems to happen it's almost
kind of like
not always it depends on who the show is
but usually whenever there's a concert
you always kind of have like a small
core of people that go to the clubs and
stuff too but then you have like this
whole bunch of other people that are all
into gothy [ __ ] but like they don't come
to the clubs ever yeah so i maybe they
just come out for special occasions or
maybe they don't like going to clubs
they just like the concert experience
some young people will show up to the
shows and they'll just be [ __ ] death
rocked [ __ ] death rocked out looked
like something from a you know fancified
1981
you know which is crazy and yeah some of
them are like
some of them are like 20. yeah they're
like 20 and they [ __ ] look great yeah
and they look like well i can show you
guys some examples and they look like
that and then you never see them at the
club you only see them at shows
so
i kind of think what the situation is is
that they're college students they don't
have a lot of money probably so they
they can only come out to a show
and um
but like uh
i'll give you guys an example of kind of
like the style that we're talking about
there it's kind of like a retro
death rock look
that
looks great to this day
would work real well in the clubs it's
just that they're not coming to the club
a lot of the clubs still looks very kind
of industrial
that's probably that might be some of
the reason why they don't why they why
they don't come to it because well and
that was kind of one of the things that
i always had issue with when it back
when i was going to the castle and stuff
like that like in the early to mid 2000s
was that i was kind of more like a
post-punk death rock kind of person and
pretty much all they played was
you know industrial
synth pop you know ebm all that kind of
stuff um which is okay but i'm not
really a huge fan of that
so
you know
pookie's coming here to say hi what's up
pokey hi
hi baby she's down by my little feet
what are you doing
what are you doing getting in trouble
you getting in trouble
camp guy said mellow mushroom today
large specialty pizza 28 bucks plus tax
yeah mellow mushroom i haven't been
there in a few years but i remember it
being kind of expensive the pizza is
good though we have a couple of them
around here
well in orlando
do you remember the other day when we
were talking about um i think this must
be on the last side track show when we
were talking about um
like
fast food chains that
weren't in some parts of the country
and i think i brought up culver's how
everybody like said culver's was really
good and i said oh we don't even have
any in florida we do there's actually
even one in orlando i didn't even know
it [ __ ] existed there's like three
within 30 miles of here which is [ __ ]
crazy i've never heard of that
i didn't know that they had culver's in
florida but i guess they do i'll have to
go check it out one of these days
that's what i'm talking about that's
kind of like the newer kind of
look that is harkening back
to the kind of the way it was in the 80s
which i think is a great look yeah i
mean they had well yeah i always really
liked that to be honest
you know
yeah and there was some people that
looked like that there last night and
then there was like then there was just
like some casual you know like said just
like old guys with bauhaus shirts on
and just people in more kind of like
casual gothy looking stuff but you did
have like a few that went all out
but
this chick's got good photos
let me see
they're talking about hoarders hoarders
yeah
the the program or people who are or
just i guess in general both things yeah
my grandfather was a hoarder i think i
probably mentioned that before
camp guy said my sister-in-law is a
hoarder
my wife is wondering what we would do if
she died and i told her the real estate
folks know people that will do a clean
out
yeah it's just
it's just kind of like if you watch that
[ __ ] show it's
some people like hoard so much stuff
that it's like even if they clean it out
they still have to like tear the house
down because it's all like the floors
collapsed and [ __ ] like that crazy
that's a another
yeah that's a good uh that's a good like
a death rock kind of
look
see if she's got some other
ones
but she's kind of like uh
trying to bring that [ __ ] back she's
been doing her homework well like i said
it's it seems like it's cyclical like it
comes because i remember there was like
kind of a death rock resurgence like in
the early to mid 2000s
um
you know what it wasn't huge but there
you did see some of it and it does seem
like there's a little bit of that going
on now too
because
i'm just i'm just glad that all that
griever [ __ ] went away yeah god that was
awful
those big [ __ ] pants yeah i remember
that [ __ ] they were jankos wearing
jenkos and [ __ ] [ __ ] hell no ugly
[ __ ] ever
this is a great photo
remember that look yeah
yeah see that's badass yeah i really
like that that was the standard for a
long time
well yeah that's why but that's what
they look like in these yeah
and early 90s you saw some of that too
robert says camp guy hoarders never
think about the family if they die then
the family got to deal with all this
stuff yeah they never do and honestly
from what i've seen like i said i had
you know a hoarder in my family and if
you watch the show hoarders most of the
people on there really don't seem to
think that they have a problem and if
you tell them hey you need to get rid of
all this [ __ ] because you know if you
croak or all the [ __ ] falls on you or
something like that then we're stuck
cleaning it out they don't really um
they just see it as this is my stuff and
you can't take it away from me
it's a psychological thing i kind of i
think it's people that
don't really have any control over a lot
of aspects of their life of their life
and that's kind of like the only thing
they can control is like all the stuff
that they have so they get really like
super attached to it
it's that and i kind of feel like too
they
it's some kind of weird psychological
thing where they're either trying to
like push people away or
something they usually i mean they
usually have like other problems too
let me go make another trick murder
hornet says can i can i get a mannequins
and a polo shirt and cargo shorts and
pick up on women
well you can probably pick up on the
normal normally women that might work
out yeah that might work out we were
actually thinking about going there like
after the show last night but by the
time
the show was at the show actually like i
said i thought it was only two bands but
it was actually four bands so it
actually ran kind of late plus they had
a couple of
um like sound issues and stuff like that
so a couple of bands like took longer
than they would have so by the time it
was over it was like already 130 or two
and then
by the time we would have got back to
mannequins it would have been almost
closing time so we didn't like bother
you know because it was just we always
say we're gonna like at the beginning of
the night it's like oh if the show ends
early we'll go to mannequins after but
it always either ends up too late or
it's or we're too [ __ ] tired
i wasn't that [ __ ] tired but it was
just it was too late by the time we got
there it would have been like we would
have been there 20 minutes and they
would have closed it up
let's see
moonpie face lady
yeah that was the one that was the one
on hoarders right the one that had the
moon pie face
i remember her and i remember was she
the same woman that was that was the bag
[ __ ]
yeah she was somehow [ __ ] her bags
into the bag
i mean it's one thing to like okay if
your toilet's broke and you can't afford
to fix it to [ __ ] in a bag but it's like
to keep the bags yeah keep the bag now i
mean it's
the first thing is weird enough but you
can kind of like understand it like
under dire circumstances but then
keeping it that's what i didn't get yeah
ridiculous i'm like why didn't you at
least bury me or something what
brian was saying uh you know i guess
he's asking me if i've seen terror on
the prairie no i haven't seen it
uh
he says he still hasn't been able to see
it oh he hasn't been able to yeah it's
stuck behind a daily wire paywall okay
i thought they didn't give a uh a
screener password you had a screen
password oh
and then um
he also said that that girl ever says
her hand everything looks like everest
scissor hands to you people yeah
that's true everything does because
you have to understand that [ __ ] well
what's his name [ __ ] tim burton was
was goth from that time well yeah so
that he fashioned all of his a lot of
his little characters as being stuff
that he liked so it was just that was a
common look for that subculture
um so people were not copying
edward scissorhands says edward
scissorhand was a copy of us
yeah well that's what always kind of
used to make me mad like after
like as much as i loved the movie
beetlejuice for example but you know
you'd be walking around the mall in 1989
and people would be like hey beetlejuice
and i'm just like i've been dressing
like this for like 10 years why
you know what i mean like at that point
um and i'm just kind of like
yeah she you know she looked awesome but
it it almost seemed like they thought
you were like dressing up as her because
her movie had to come out but i was like
no um i looked like this before just
think of how ridiculous it was
it would be if
if a movie came out with hippies in it
back in the seven back in back in the
60s
and you were a hippie and people thought
that you were copying a movie that had
hippies in it but no you were a [ __ ]
hippie the movie was about hippies
it's like that it's kinda like that
thank you [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the godzilla was basically kind of like
a
an offshoot
of the [ __ ] punk rock scene
you can trace it pretty much to [ __ ]
susie sue
from susie in the bed she's she kind of
invented the look
well
at least for women for girls for girls
she invented the look
the [ __ ]
the original guy look
was probably was invented by sid vicious
really kind of and
dressed him up like that lou reed was
kind of doing some kind of gothy [ __ ]
too but i i kinda i'm gonna say no i'm
gonna say that was [ __ ] sid vicious
sid vicious
and nancy [ __ ] dresses it up like
that
and it was based on new york stuff and
[ __ ] new york fetish type clothes and
black leather and
spiky black hair and
uh
i mean and it was real [ __ ] um
it was real outrageous i mean [ __ ]
sid vicious wore a [ __ ] red
[ __ ] swastika shirt with the [ __ ]
sleeves cut off of it
it's just ridiculous you couldn't wear
that [ __ ] but he would
you were a [ __ ] swastika well that
was kind of the whole point was like to
provoke yeah
you know i mean well you had stuff like
back then like nick cave would walk
around like wearing a shirt that said
the only good cop is a dead cop yeah um
or like you know two two cowboys two
cowboys like
each other right yeah stuff like that it
would anything to like get a reaction
uh murder hornet return says do gods
hate normies no
no not generally i mean unless they're
unless they act like douches then yeah
then yeah we do but if you're just
standing there then no see this is
another [ __ ] thing that people don't
understand
[Laughter]
most people are conformist
they want to be like everybody else
okay whatever they believe they want
everybody else to believe that you see
this in what being widespread in society
today if you don't agree with me you're
wrong that's the attitude
and this is being [ __ ] propagated
through [ __ ]
through [ __ ] propaganda channels if
you don't think like i do you're wrong
you're a bad person
and that's really been the kind of
[ __ ] the mainstay of human society
going back for thousands of years
you know when theocracies were like that
monarchies and [ __ ] were like that if
you're not like us you're wrong
if everybody was like goths if everybody
was a goth we would be mundane
[Laughter]
we do not want other people to be like
us at all
society couldn't function if it was all
goths nothing would get done
we need you normal [ __ ] out
there working making money drilling for
[ __ ] oil
building cars making computers get
gunning one of those things too [ __ ]
yeah
you need electricity to be gods we need
to have [ __ ] all this [ __ ] done if
these [ __ ] were all goff none
of that would happen they because we'll
[ __ ] that
no i do that's not true a lot of them
would go [ __ ] no you're not going to get
gus to do underwater [ __ ] welding all
right well the bottom of a [ __ ] oil
rig well you're not going to get most
normal
people
that's what i'm saying
everything is has a specialized function
in the in an advanced society
and goths are only something that's
going to come out of an advanced society
and they're going to be kind of like
there's going to be a subculture and if
it becomes mainstream the people who are
goth will leave it
they'll go this [ __ ] this shit's [ __ ]
normy [ __ ] man i'm out
that's cause that's the personality
there's a lot of [ __ ] we would wear
that was cutting edge back in the 80s
and 90s that is now normie where we you
don't wear that
okay norman's wearing it
okay
because
over time if you look
okay i can dig up old photographs old
photographs of [ __ ] goth girlfriends
from the 90s that i had
that looked goth as [ __ ]
now look at those photos now and that's
just something that the regular chick
would be wearing
yeah no one would really like no one
would look at it
then that was like yeah because nobody
looked like that nobody looked like that
back then
well like i said i kind of feel like you
know tim burton and um you know lars and
marilyn manson and stuff like that kind
of mainstreamed the look because you
remember like in the 90s like you know
you have those movies like the crow and
[ __ ] like that so
you know a lot more people were seeing
that look and like liking it so like
fashion designers were like picking up
on it and [ __ ] like that so it kind of
got to a point where it wasn't as weird
anymore like to look like that yeah you
know what i mean
um the jumping off of that danny rowling
says are poser goths easy to spot yeah
usually yeah usually yeah this is she'd
have to be like pretty good at it yeah
the shoes are usually the dead giveaway
yep um and pretty much every goth every
old person like every old goth knows
that
it's always the shoes it's the shoes
i don't know why i don't know why it's
always the shoes because
[Laughter]
because a person who's not a goth looks
at the outfit all right they're looking
at the outfit another a goth is wearing
this i want that outfit so they go for
the biggest things that they see which
are shirts and pads pants and jackets
but they don't they're not look at the
footwear the footwear is at the bottom
of the [ __ ] list all right but they
don't understand it's the footwear that
makes that [ __ ] outfit
i could just put i could just put my new
rocks on and just have some black jeans
and a right t-shirt and i'd still look
goth and it's because of the [ __ ]
shoes yeah yeah the shoes make the
[ __ ]
a lot of girls are out there [ __ ] it
you know and
doing [ __ ] industrial type [ __ ] at
the goth club and they're out and if you
actually analyze what they're wearing
it's [ __ ] that they got off a [ __ ]
amazon a couple bucks a pop stretchy
black [ __ ] but because they have the
right shoes on and the right accessories
it turns it into a goth outfit
yeah because you don't really have to
spend like a [ __ ] ton of money i mean
you can get stuff just from like [ __ ]
targets
it's all in how you put it together like
a lot of people kind of like and how hot
that girl is that too uh you know some
people like cut them creatively like you
know it all depends on like the jewelry
the belts the way you do your hair or
like the shoes like you said it's you
know it's so it's all kind of like goes
together some of those girls are smoking
hot the less they have on the better
they look they just put their boots on
and [ __ ] accessories and [ __ ]
something skimpy and it it's got this
hell
but that's her figure and all those ex
and all those [ __ ] accessories and
those boots it's not the
clothes per se
the clothes might just be a [ __ ]
stretch stretch mini skirt
that's anything you know three dollars
or like black electrical tape black
electrical tape over there
but she's got a rocking set of implants
and she's looking really good she's just
got a big [ __ ] plant
x over the nipples
they were yeah there was a little
miniature
like back in the old days the right hair
and [ __ ] yeah
yeah because you see it sometimes where
people like i mean at least sometimes
people make an effort they don't just
come in there like looking like they
just were mowing the lawn or whatever
but
sometimes you have
you know you'd see this at eye bar you
see the castle a lot like back when i
used to go there was that especially
girls and they would come there and
they'd be like oh we're going to the
goth club so we got it so they'd have
like the one black dress that they had
yeah that was old because that was like
what they were to funerals and then they
would try to like do some [ __ ] with
their hair like they just had regular
like brown hair or whatever so they try
to like pull it back and kind of tease
it or like spray like purple on the
edges or something like that and it's
like they would do something like that i
was like oh at least they're trying yeah
but like i said a lot of that has to do
with who that girl is what she looks
like if that girl's [ __ ] smoking hot
she can get a [ __ ] 10 [ __ ] just
off the rack wednesday adams dress with
sleeveless with a little white collar on
it and the right set of boots that's all
she needs
but the thing is is that usually she's
already kind of famous everybody knows
who she is she's been around so she
really doesn't have to prove
her street cred all right everybody
knows what her wardrobe looks like she's
you know i've been around forever you
know everything she has
you see the clothes that she's got they
do kind of keep track of what you got
well you kind of have to because
sometimes you have like because i have
in particular like i think there's one
or two pieces that i have that i know
for a fact that with that another chick
has the same thing
so you always have to kind of like worry
that
because you know
it's it's a small goth world after all
and
every now and then one of us is going to
come across the same thing like on
on one of the websites and be like oh i
gotta have that [ __ ] on the same night
so then yeah you really gotta like watch
it so sometimes i remember i'm not
saying what her name is but i have this
really i have this really cool like um
red vinyl shrug and i know that there's
another girl that has that exact same
one
so i always had so i wouldn't wear it
wouldn't wear it wouldn't wear it and
then i'd see her wear it like one week
and then be like okay well i can wear it
next week i'll be safe
[Laughter]
i just bought her a dress she wore last
night [ __ ] it was funny it's like
a few days after i bought it i looked
down the dance floor and the girl was
wearing it yeah
afterwards i went you know don't get
pissed but i bought her that dress
[Laughter]
going to be here in a couple days and
she goes yeah how much did you pay for
it does it pay 40's because i got mine
for 20. and i said no [ __ ] dude because
yeah i got it off well i just got to
watch a wish oh yeah really
you got to watch with women women women
women are [ __ ] have it a lot easier
than guys they have a lot more selection
of clothes and they're a lot cheaper
than guy clothes a lot cheaper well
mostly the [ __ ] goth guy closer
[ __ ] defensive well the thing about
it though is that a lot of times um yeah
some of the women's clothes aren't that
expensive but a lot of them aren't super
good quality either yeah you only wear
them a couple times to fall back yeah
that's what i'm saying and well and
actually even like regular clothes
um
women's clothes and i've seen like a lot
of people complain about this even if
you get them in like department stores
and [ __ ] like that
you get them kind of cheap but they're
super see-through so you always have to
like buy something else like to go
underneath it otherwise everyone's gonna
see your boobies you know what i mean
um you know and like i said they don't
really last all that long they're not
really
supposed to last so
they just kind of
i don't know they just kind of like make
you buy new stuff like with the new
fashions or whatever but yeah i mean she
usually goes the girl that has that same
dress
uh she is kind of like she was an eyebar
saturday person
and
she goes to mannequins i think on
fridays
so
i just can't wear it to that i was kind
of scared to wear it last night to the
show because i was like oh that sounds
like a show that she would go to but she
wasn't there i can show a video
last night
tom posted it
the guys will enjoy it tom was [ __ ]
taking pictures of the girls and there's
some girls oh man again yeah up on a
stripper pole [ __ ] ass hanging out
and i was going i looked at that and
says i gotta get jenny that outfit
hold on let me see if i can find it
there's normies in there
yeah they're always the girls going what
the [ __ ]
fourth drawdown says goths don't hate
anyone yeah we generally don't i mean
unless you're a real super douche then
we do yeah but everyone would hate you
if you were super huge uh they like what
they like and don't hide it yeah exactly
in the 80s i knew gossip were into abba
and tom jones at a time when it was
social suicide for normies
hey abba and tom jones are good i like
them too we were actually talking about
that on the way home how because i was
talking about because we were talking
about june loves jezebel
and
they had done um
motion of love and i said i remember
buying that
single like a 45 a vinyl single like
when it came out and i remember not
buying the whole album even though i had
all their other like their older [ __ ]
because i was like well that song was
like so poppy
and i was like ooh they're going like
all poppy and mainstream and i don't
like it anymore
um so i bought that one song and i
didn't really like it and i said and
it's funny now because now when you
listen to it it doesn't really sound all
that different than their older stuff
just in hindsight and there was like a
lot of music that i hated that was like
mainstream during the 80s
um that i couldn't stand we were talking
about like [ __ ] hauling oats and
stuff like that
and then but like if you listen to it
now you're like you know what that's
pretty good
but you could have you know i didn't
like it at the time
but
it's if you listen to it now it's like
not that bad
i think he took it down oh did he really
see
maybe somebody [ __ ] yelled at him
about it
although you would think tom be like
nope keep that [ __ ] up
yeah i wonder what happened with it i
don't know well if it's the one that i
was thinking of was it um it's from last
night was it jenna shay
uh i don't know if it was jenna shea she
looked kind of thick to be jenna shay oh
i just saw it real quick so i didn't it
looked like jenna shea butter was it
jenna shea bear on the on the pole with
her friend oh she wasn't on the pole she
was on the floor like on the dance floor
no
oh okay
maybe it was a different one that i saw
then and i don't know if it was her i
was just
i just thought she's there all the time
because her and damian are always sell
their artwork in the front
so that's i just like saw it quick so i
thought that's who it was
yeah i'm seeing pictures of people just
walking around out there
maybe maybe it wasn't mannequin lounge
maybe it was uh let me see
maybe it was tom morris
murder hornet return says back in the
90s me and a friend accidentally walked
into a club in nashville we said [ __ ]
this and turn right back around
oh i found it oh you did yeah hold on
let me [ __ ] full screen this [ __ ]
look
who is that goes pants around the corner
here
tom fans around the corner looks who's
that
oh um
i don't know who that was good
i couldn't really tell oh [ __ ] don't you
watch it
pants around the corner
and they got her
that's a cool bartender yeah she's
awesome i love her yeah is that andy
that
uh yeah i think no andy didn't go she
was with us oh that's right yeah but i
thought oh i thought this was a
different night okay no this is last
night oh all right who is that i don't
know
see how they say
see i was saying people how
they could be wearing next to nothing
but it looks goth as hell that's just a
little short mini dress and there's some
stockings and some garters and the right
shoes
and she's got like the long black hair
yeah she's got the long black hair bags
and she's got the little fetish booty
shoes boot shoes on
i don't know who that is walking away
well just the hair it looked like andy
because andy's hair was like that last
night but and she usually wears her hair
like that but
who is that i don't know i can't figure
it out it's not a that's not um
that was an ari was it
no
she doesn't have hair like that that's
true her hair's blonde
yeah i guess that's black hair right now
yeah
dj maniac said i have one club buddy i
have to pre-plan with i don't want to
showing up in the same shirt and look
like a [ __ ] fan club yeah that's the
thing i mean
i don't i don't usually have too much
trouble you know what i mean because i
don't usually have like the same outfits
as other people and i'd
honestly it's better to have like
separate pieces because then you can
kind of like mix and match them so even
if you kind of have the same shirt on
at least i'll have like a different belt
or different jewelry or different pants
or whatever so it's kind of like
john goris said my favorite clothing
item is an old army jacket i literally
found abandoned in a parking lot
[Laughter]
one of my favorite uh clothing pieces
growing up was i found this trench coat
before you know columbine and the trench
coat mafia and all that this was like
back in the [ __ ] 80s
i found a trench coat in
a thrift store for three dollars
and it was either black or like a super
super dark green and like the inside was
like bright orange paisley and i just
thought that was hilarious
i wore that [ __ ] thing forever like
even when it was hot i would have like
my [ __ ] alien sex fiend shirt yeah
and my and my trench coat and my little
my little army boots
my little shaved head ghost face calls
it guff frankenstein boots
the footwear is always something extreme
it's either some big platforms or it's a
super aggressive
tiny pointy
toe
stiletto
dominatrix looking boot something like
that something that
used to squash men's nuts in porn movies
it's something like that
i i enjoy the nut squash nut squashing
porn and [ __ ]
putting his junk through a damn hole in
the board he's like standing on his back
like that
[ __ ]
is that hurt
me and jen came across some [ __ ] like
that [ __ ] we were looking at the porn
and jenny was [ __ ] laughing her ass
off i was [ __ ] cringing
that's part of why i was laughing she
was putting one testicle up against that
thing and put ticking her toe and
crushing that dude's name oh
yeah
i couldn't look i couldn't love you
she's sitting there laughing
you got to do that [ __ ] to get off man
you are [ __ ] up man
damn
i wonder how much money i could get
squashing dudes nuts without making [ __ ]
a ton of movies
i could i'd probably have a good time
doing it yeah it's just nut squash hey
the more i mean and then like another
one the more it hurts the more they like
it oh okay and then that scent hurt and
that same check she was in this [ __ ]
real
red pvc mini dress
[ __ ] just
only covered the top half her ass and
she had those [ __ ] same boots on and
she was [ __ ] taking a running [ __ ]
start and kicking that dude right in the
nuts
[Laughter]
and she'd run like [ __ ] three steps
and go back like that it was a real kick
like
like a man kicking another man you know
i mean bam and he's oh
nasty [ __ ] man you said you've got to
have some serious problems if that's
what it takes to get off see now see
that's the kind of porn i could get
[ __ ] problems i would have i would
have a blast doing porn like that
just like kicking dudes in the nuts and
stepping on their testicles all day long
[ __ ] that that would be super fun i
think
[Laughter]
sorry guys
i just think that would be really i
think that would be a really
entertaining way to make money it's like
just like squish your testicles like a
[ __ ] cockroach
don't tear it up oh she's she's gonna
john gore says pop from the 80s is
really well put together music
especially the early 80s yeah it really
is and i think
you know because i was uh you know a
teenager and i was into like uh you know
gothy [ __ ] and post punk and everything
which i still am but so i was just like
pop music ew you know what i mean but
when i listen to it now like stuff back
from the 80s i'm like oh you know what
that's pretty good that's pretty good
you know what i mean you're asking is it
hard for a gut to get away [ __ ]
wearing the same office more uh no you
can wear them you can wear it several
times but you got to have a bunch of
them
like i said it's better the same thing
over and over again it's better to have
like some a few pieces that you can like
mix and match and have some different
yeah and have some different like
accessories like you can get cheap like
belts or like some kind of like jewelry
or like i said i got wigs and
i have a couple different pairs of boots
and [ __ ] like that yeah another thing is
is that you know there's a lot we're
talking about fashion this is culture
and fashion which is kind of away from
the the show topic but this is this is
the sidetrack show there isn't a topic
that's kind of the whole all right
[ __ ]
that scene has its own history in its
own culture
the fashion changed over decades
there's a bunch of different influences
so in a way it's kind of a code
you'll see people coming and they're
wearing something that's
retro or hearkening back to another era
that seems sweetie
it may not
wouldn't make any sense to a person who
doesn't know the history but other guys
know exactly what
what that outfit means so it's not you
know what i mean like well you know what
they're into you know what they like to
do from the way that they or you know
what just hearkening back to it oh
that's like that's like adamant from 81
or whatever there's such something you
know what i mean it just depends on what
that person's doing
yeah that that's the thing it's there's
always kind of like i know like to
people that aren't in this it's like
kind of everybody looks oh they all look
like the same yeah like i said they all
look like everyone
because you always kind of know that
person you know that that
you can tell there's because you know
goth music is not like one
uh you know just one thing there's like
a bajillion different subgenres
so you can tell like what kind of [ __ ]
that person we had our own we have our
own celebrities and stuff
so and we know what happened back in the
past so you know
you might have some dude want to jump
just appear out of nowhere looking like
[ __ ] john koviak you know and you
guys don't know who john koviak is but
we know who john koviak is
so
we can do stuff that works for us so you
would you guys wouldn't understand it
[Laughter]
dj maniac says not entirely true i dress
like an og and i'm into pretty much
everything yeah honestly people that
more kind of dress old school generally
do tend to have like a wider
i kind of feel like the people that are
just more into because you know you do
get some people that are just more into
i don't know just like more like hard
industrial kind of stuff or power noise
or whatever the [ __ ] um and they usually
look a specific way yeah that yes the
little sub cult sub genres of the
culture another thing is is that some
people just show up and they're young
they're young they're new they don't
have much money they're just learning
things so they're gonna be they're gonna
look different
you know yeah and they're at the
beginning of their little [ __ ]
journey
they used to call them baby bats yeah i
don't know if that nomenclature is still
but you got some guys that show up like
nick who [ __ ] like like my adopted
son nick that's someone called
he pretty much knew a lot before he ever
even showed up in a club
he knew good bands and yeah i mean he
showed up and he was 19. and he looked
great he was ending the right [ __ ] yeah
he had like [ __ ] he had he was all
christian deaf and all of a sudden i was
just kind of like look bad dude i'm like
he looks like a baby
yeah and yet
yeah he broke i'm like he's doing it
right broke up with his girlfriend the
next thing you know these [ __ ] 50
year old hot girl chicks pulling him in
the bathroom and blowing him and [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] molesting that young
boy
well he's a he's 21. he's a nice boy
he's 20 he's 21. it's legal but uh he
was at the show he was at the show last
night and i said dude man all these
[ __ ] goth moms are [ __ ] sitting
here scoping out
that's like bath mobs yes and they're
just about moms now well not even then
the god they're just like moms so these
god moms are checking you out man
[ __ ] he's like yeah well it happens
all the time
because i imagine because he you know
he's tall he's skinny and he [ __ ]
knows how to dress and he's got that
look that
teenage goth girls universally like
and they grow up to be women and that
they're just going like oh yeah you know
then i used to hit dudes that looked
just like
back in my day back in my day yeah
that's how they start reliving their
[ __ ] youth you know
it's always funny though it's always
like entertaining to me whenever you go
to a show like we did last night and
going to see jean loves jezebel whenever
you go see
a kind of like
not a real obscure goth band from back
in the 80s but like one that was kind of
better known that maybe had like a
couple hits and stuff
uh you always get it's always kind of
like half and half you always kind of
get like gods like old ones and young
ones and then you get like a bunch of
like you said like a bunch of like
normally looking moms and dads who
obviously they're like i used to look
like that back in the old days yeah but
now they [ __ ] i'm older than you it's
like
why don't you look like that anymore
though
if you were that much into it i mean you
were into it enough to pay twenty
dollars to say jean loves jezebel no
i don't understand well it's like well i
had to have a job and i have kids and
blah blah blah i'm like that's no excuse
no excuse we know lots of guys that have
kids
and their kids are no more [ __ ] up
than anyone else's kids
maybe laura's got two or three of them
and she's still suspended herself from
the ceilings with hooks and [ __ ] [ __ ]
she you would not know
you couldn't really tell how old she was
yeah you would you wouldn't think of
that as someone's mom but she totally
well and that's what i mean like a lot
of well like jazz that was there last
night big tall skinny girl big green
mohawk and stuff like that
she's also someone's mom yeah uh but so
you just wouldn't know like looking at
that but a lot of people a lot of them
are someone yeah i'm gonna show you guys
who i'm talking about
okay
that's aurora and that's somebody's mom
that's several that's something yeah
she's got two or three kids okay how
many she got i think she's got three i
think it's three and she uh she's a
suspension performance she's she'll put
big old damn
spikes through her back and they'll
suspend her from the ceiling and she'll
be swinging around from rafters and [ __ ]
dj maniac says edm fans all have the
same generic look yeah military gear
high and tight haircuts yeah they all
kind of look like that they all kind of
look like that
and dj maniac also said i look a lot
younger than i'm supposed to
yeah
i found that like um
a lot of a lot of people that are into
the goth subculture are a lot older than
they look
like it's very you maybe it's because
they stay out of the sun
or maybe it's just because you see them
in the dark all the time maybe that's
what it is you never really see it in
like bright sunlight you can see all
their wrinkles man the women are very
deceptive i mean you know jenny's
coming up on 50 there's a lot of
girls that are
from the scene that are coming up on 50
some of them are still
some of them are in the adult at the
entertainment industry like remember
them big old big titty
yeah what's her name she's your age yeah
and nobody knows
how old how old she is i'll get a
picture of her
she hasn't been around a long time
though yeah i haven't seen her in a
while um
she's around but she's working john
goris says my graying hair is the big
tail i'm not dying anything though
honestly but why not i mean i mean if
you want to you should because i've been
dying my hair for not because it was
great it's probably gray now but i
started dying it a long time before it
was great just because i wanted it to be
black because it was easier
you know what i mean she's jenny's age
she's almost 50. yeah okay
yeah fourth rhodes says you don't see
gods at the beach too often yeah you
don't i mean it's it's not usually a
thing it's not a thing
yeah i haven't seen her in ages no
she's around though she just doesn't
come out anymore well she used to go to
the fetish parties all the time yeah
that escape she's married to a chick
that looks just like her the big boobs
and everything yeah they're like they're
like little twins yeah and then they
they do dudes for a living they got
boyfriends too it's weird
and they're
those two are super nice yeah yeah super
nice
what's up poop
but yeah they used to come to the fetish
parties all the time yeah but you would
not know think
you would not think that that's a 50
year old woman
it's just yeah it's really not something
that
i don't know like i said it's really not
something that occurs to
people i guess you just come to the you
come to the club you like the music you
just you know you want to dress up and
[ __ ] like that and
nobody's really like worried about how
old you are it was dj maniac
hey did he get here
probably yeah yeah he's like hey that's
where is
that's right murder hornet says milf
goth booty tang
pooty tang sorry booty tank
i can't read
i can't read
yeah i mean i
i've thought about growing because my
hair like i said my hair is red like
naturally
but like a like coppery reddish orange
but it's probably gray at this point i'm
sure
so
it's just easier to like slap black dye
on it
kind of keeps it healthier
it go black goes with everything
i have a weird thing where i always have
to like color coordinate [ __ ] you know
what i mean so i always kind of feel
like well if i let my hair grow back out
and it's red then i can only have like
red accessories
like because if i wear like some other
thing like if i were this that has like
hot pink and blue on it like it'll clash
and i don't like that
yeah dj does look like rob zombie he
looks like he looks a little bit like a
skinny rob zombie though i think right
rob zombie's a little [ __ ] he's a
little heavier and he
i have not seen rum zombie in a while i
think he's kind of i think i mean he's
not well rob zombie i don't think he's
fat he's just like i think he blah blah
he's just big i think he booked he's
just big but he doesn't he'd never
struck me as like fat no
i think the last time i saw rob zombie
was like on one of those horror he's
getting mad he's going to take it back
they're going golly over [ __ ] the uh
princess
pinky
[Laughter]
yeah one way they don't come out anymore
they were only coming out on fetish
nights
yeah that was the only time we ever saw
them because that escaped they didn't go
to the end of the other things
they were more they were more like into
fetish stuff
i don't think they were really because
the there's a lot of overlap between the
goth scene and the fetish scene but it's
not necessarily the same thing
they all know each other there's a lot
of people that are into fetish [ __ ] that
aren't into god [ __ ]
there are some guys in the fetish though
yeah they all knew everybody knows each
other pretty much
you recognize them you go yeah yeah
those used to be fun those parties they
don't have them like they used to no
they had them i think southern knights
is still there yeah but you know you
know who's big into that is [ __ ] uh
dimitri and jen they love fetish stuff
yeah maybe we ought to [ __ ] throw a
fetish thing
you think
we do it at southern knights i wonder
what southern knights wants
i mean i think they're still around
right
as far as i know for it i don't know
make money with it i mean i mean that's
a nice place like i said it looks like a
dump from the outside but like the
inside is really big and really nice
supposed to outback it looks like a
[ __ ] tiki bar for [ __ ] hell and
love motel it's massive it has like a
big theater in there and then like
there's another room with like a big
dance floor and like this big yeah it's
like when this really swanky like all
these white bricks and yeah all these
fancy bars and [ __ ] what's great about
it's it's i think normally a gay slash
drag bar that's what it is what it is
yeah i mean it's it's gay and drag
pretty much all the time but we were
having fetish nights there yeah like
once a month once a month then they had
a
the music was goth industrial though and
a lot of goth overlap got people coming
and it was great
because uh
man during the summer you just get hot
as [ __ ] and you can just get blasted in
there and [ __ ] you could take your
shirt off and [ __ ] walk around out
back remember that [ __ ] yeah your heels
broke and [ __ ] we were hanging out
with that other check and her [ __ ]
shoe broke and [ __ ]
you stand out in a [ __ ] back [ __ ]
like half naked got out this
truck
and it doesn't matter there everyone's
like whatever
yeah
well they would do a theme every month
yeah i did see
it would be like i remember them doing
like scary disney because i remember
being scary poppins yeah
and yeah so they always had costume
parties yeah it was like a costume party
and there's a theater in there yeah it
has a stage and a and they do like game
[ __ ] like dirty game shows yeah and
you'd win pride like you'd win like yeah
bar tabs and [ __ ] like i was up on stage
trying to [ __ ] win these prizes like
because they call people up
[ __ ] do the prizes and [ __ ] one of
them was they had to
they had a cat box filled with [ __ ]
rice krispies it was like cat litter
with [ __ ] tootsie rolls tootsie rolls
[ __ ] like [ __ ] yeah they had to dig
through there and find these little
[ __ ] pieces with your mouth and you
had like with your mouth and you can't
find the prizes and [ __ ]
i actually had to
they gave me porn i remember that yeah
we got yeah we got like some free porn
videos
like well not videos but they were dvds
we got porn dvds um and also i think i
won
i i won like a little like a vibrating
egg or like some like some handcuffs
like [ __ ] like that and they'd pay your
bar tab and they pay your bar tab and
stuff yeah the one time i went up there
i think i had to didn't i have to like
but they gave me like shaving cream or
whipped cream or something like that and
i had to like soap up those girls butts
yeah and then like kind of like they had
like blow up dildos and stuff yeah i
don't remember exactly i was kind of
drunk i don't know what was going on
yeah you're not really having sex it's
not he's not having sex it's all gags
it's all gags
but i remember i think i still have
those yeah i i won like what were they
like they were hot pink handcuffs yeah i
think
i think i still have them somewhere
but yeah i'd say i remember winning
those yeah that was that was [ __ ]
mike stone
yeah he died and mike stone died so
maybe we ought to [ __ ] try to open
that up
and well
all these dudes [ __ ] die they die
young the women all died cancer
every dude that we've known that died
died of some kind of [ __ ] weird drug
related thing
except for except for ld he died in a
car crash ld died in a car wreck yeah
he was a dj yeah
and and uh he didn't have long to live
anyway ld was a dwarf and he had bad
problems with his liver his kidneys and
[ __ ] yeah it wasn't just that he was a
dwarf he had a bunch of bad health
problems yeah
but yeah he died in a car wreck like
somebody he was a freak actually he was
yeah he was like waiting to get on i-4 i
think he was on like an exit ramp and
some random ass person like just came
and like [ __ ] hit him yeah out of
nowhere because and like a year before
that he's like man i don't think i'm
gonna be around much longer i was like
yeah that bad honey because yeah i i
don't think i'm gonna make it i mean
he's in bad health [ __ ] and i was a
dude i'm sorry to hear that you know i'm
[ __ ] and and you know it says you're
a good dj man you're real amusing too
i didn't want to tell you know a lot of
people think you're an [ __ ]
i think he knew that how do you do that
he knew that
but uh he says you're amusing man for
yours you're good to have around
and he's like yeah uh i'm just my this
body this little body is just not built
right man if i can and i said well you
got to look at it this way
we all die eventually and then we're
released from all these [ __ ] physical
boundaries we can become cosmic
creatures
maybe to reincarnate because he goes
yeah i'm gonna come back as an eagle you
know [ __ ] like that
yeah anyway i hope he did yeah the he uh
died in a freak car accident yeah that
would happen to anybody it was a freak
he got rear-ended he was the only person
that died in that wreck too it was like
it was so bizarre yeah i remember like i
remember i don't remember who caught who
called me and told me
but i remember somebody didn't
but i was like man that is [ __ ] up
yeah it was crazy
well it's like we heard about the
accident first and we didn't know they
were like oh one person died and we
didn't know who it was and then we found
out who that one guy i think his name
was tom too it's been a long time so
i've even said that guy's name remember
he was my age he had that real hot young
girlfriend
and he was died in the hotel room
sleeping next to her
she woke up remember that she woke up
and he was dead next to her oh i forgot
about it yeah
yeah
that's so weird yeah
i mean that's the thing like i like his
ass under control he was running around
[ __ ] pistol
he would go to the clubs with [ __ ]
packing
and he was starting to get never a good
idea yeah he was starting to get
paranoid
all right
and he thought people were after him
and i said
he was he was a drug dealer
you know yeah he's a drug dealer
basically
and um
i said man you need to [ __ ] chill the
[ __ ] out okay you're in here drinking
you're high as [ __ ] and you're [ __ ]
carrying all right and he was
uh
he was he was a ticking time bomb
um
but he died in his sleep
[ __ ] weird man i mean it's probably
good that he didn't like take other
people out yeah you know yeah well the
thing about it is that i know like the
way we talk about it it sounds like this
big [ __ ] but honestly like most
people in the scene are like really
chill yeah and normal yeah
yeah yeah kinda not really i mean well
not really the thing about it though is
that normal people yeah are absolutely
not normal no don't pretend that they're
normal
and a lot of times normal people are
sometimes worse because i feel like
they're trying to hide it right uh at
least most of the time like gossip
they're kind of [ __ ] up like you kind
of know they're [ __ ] up like they
don't really make a big secret about it
and the guy that i was telling you about
i think his first name was tom that was
[ __ ]
11 years ago
the guy who died to sleep i think his
name was tom i mean yeah that i think
that was his name but yeah that was a
that was a while back long time ago 12
years ago i only knew the guy for a
couple years and just from the clubs he
wasn't really a goth
he hung out in the goth scene he was
cool
he was drug dealer though really yeah
and he was ex-military and [ __ ] you
know
you look at him even it's not the
stereotypical
thing that you would think of a drug
dealer you know
when you looked at him he looked like a
cop he carried himself kind of like a
cop
he had training and everything it's just
that he was just going down this to slow
descent of [ __ ] drugs he'd lost
everything that he owned because he had
a regular job when it started and then
he just [ __ ] drugs drug addiction
turned him into a drug dealer
which had benefits to it it had its own
benefits from his point of view he
didn't have anything to worry about
he just lived in hotels
and
had these young druggie women
you know hanging off of him all the time
and he was having fun
he was in his 40s i think at that time
and um
made a lot of money in cash but he
didn't own anything he had a car
and you know he would buy clothes and
he would say that he didn't do laundry
it's just that when his clothes got
dirty just threw him away and he bought
more clothes
you couldn't buy anything he couldn't
buy anything big because he just had
cash income right
so yeah you don't want to be looking at
it yeah
so because not a lot of people have
whole cash incomes right everybody's
gonna be like drug dealer yeah
and he couldn't like
evidently couldn't or didn't want to
rent a house because he wanted to keep
moving so nobody know where he was
i mean in a way like yeah he's probably
like more paranoid than was warranted
but
i mean it's probably good if that's your
line of work to like to be cautious for
sure
i don't think i i don't think that like
moving from place to place and not like
owning it or not buying anything like
big i don't think that's like over the
top i mean i would probably do that too
if i was a driver he was living in a
disposable life right everything was
just disposable
weird i mean i've known other guys that
lived that way too
and uh
they said that [ __ ] in that in the in
the trade as they'd call it
they'd start throwing ones away because
ones were too bulky
they'd end up with a damn gym bag full
of ones you could throw the [ __ ] ones
away well i mean they could just like
they just throw them almost yeah they'd
throw them [ __ ] to
put guys begging on the side of the road
and they go [ __ ] crazy for the ones
and [ __ ]
because it's just too much
and you know they couldn't spend it all
and then the supplier keeps forcing more
and more product on them sell this sell
this dude i can't sell that sell it or
else oh man look at this [ __ ] look at
all this
you know see that's how they get you
yeah
more and more and more
and these dudes are dangerous yeah
might be fun for a little while but that
particular guy i'm talking about
said that he finally
he finally realized that that they
weren't keeping track over how much they
gave him just as long as he kept sending
the money they didn't care i don't know
so sometimes he would just like i can't
sell all this he just throw a lot of it
away and then he'd get another shipment
in and he'd just start over as long as
he was giving them bags of 20s
they were happy they weren't even
counting it they would just go yeah it
feels good
just they kind of weight with their hand
that feels good they throw it in the
back of the truck
and then [ __ ] kick out a big old
[ __ ] thing of
coke
or
heroin or something kick it out the
[ __ ] back of a truck and [ __ ]
leave take off just be out in a wooded
area
they got there with aks and [ __ ]
central american guys so you [ __ ]
[ __ ] around those dudes man
i gotta i got that [ __ ] on video what
they'll do to you if you [ __ ] them over
dangerous life
but that's what happened to that guy he
just second um died in his sleep
from something that he did
weird
maybe he just took a little bit too much
or his body was just like nope i'm out
he was looking in bad shape you remember
him
yeah you remember remember yeah i mean
it's been a while i could tell he was
under a lot of stress physically and
mentally
running his mouth had a [ __ ] pistol
in his head a pistol in his [ __ ]
waistband [ __ ] eye bar
yeah yeah nice downtown yeah that's not
a good idea yeah in the club
jacked
loaded
drinking and firearms don't mix yeah and
drugs
and and drugs yeah and drugs yeah that's
that's not a good idea
yeah
i mean very very easy to get mad at
somebody yeah get mad at him
yeah then you're in prison he was kind
of [ __ ] getting to the point where he
thought people were after him that
weren't after him you know
so he was getting paranoid and he was
dead a couple weeks later
that was the last time i saw him
i just and it was the last time i saw
that girl
remember her yeah like whatever she was
pretty what happened ended up happening
to her though she just vanished i think
i traumatized her
well yeah i mean it would yeah
yeah that's another thing these dudes
have [ __ ] remarkably good-looking
women they're not not losers
well they got money and drugs you got
money
yeah drugs
camp guys said my old man used to pick
up every coin he saw on the ground
pennies to nickels dimes and quarters he
was a millionaire when he died
did he really pick up that many nickels
holy crap i never i don't know where all
these people are finding like i guess i
don't walk around outside all that much
but i don't i don't i don't know where
you guys are seeing all these coins
nobody carries coins anymore i kind of
feel like you're not going to be a
millionaire nowadays going around
picking up coins because nobody carries
any cash or coins or nothing
about howard stern hurt his butt with a
large toy
you have to [ __ ] put more information
in on that did he stick one of those
things like up his butt
yeah i stopped listening to howard stern
around
i don't know
2002 or three
did he used to stick stuff up his butt
on no no no not that i know of
maybe he did later maybe he did
[Laughter]
fourth round says have you seen a movie
called american made i don't think so
i don't think so
yeah camp guy said he was born in 1930
so he had to live very frugally during
the great depression yeah i do kind of
feel like that happened a lot with
people from that era because they were
just used they saved everything you know
because that's just what they were used
to doing
yeah he said i saw it on netflix but i
don't know if it's on there now
and let's see
murder hornet says i've been approached
few times by the cartel to smuggle guns
and drugs i'm like no way
day you start doing business with them
you sign your own death warrant sooner
or later you can't ever stop that's what
i'm saying it's like it's it's not just
oh i'll just do this for a year or two
and then i'll retire yeah that's not how
that [ __ ] works out i mean they're gonna
use you up that's what i'm saying like
i'm sure it's cool like cause you're
making a [ __ ] ton of money uh but yeah
it's dangerous and you're gonna get on
the wrong side of them at some point and
they're gonna like kill your ass or
you're gonna get killed like doing some
other [ __ ]
it's not worth it they're going to
before they even deal with you they
probably have to know everything about
you unless they're friends of yours i
mean you know you can see that you can
see cocaine cowboys a movie on netflix
that explains how it was here in florida
with the with the uh with the cubans
the cuban americans but that was that
was a long time ago
and those particular guys got into that
business they weren't criminals when
they started
they just kind of they weren't very
ruthless
they didn't kill some guys later on
because they were trying to not go to
prison
but they weren't as ruthless as say like
ms-13 or the mexican mob those guys are
already set in their ways and
they [ __ ] you up
i don't think it's worth it it's just
really not
and i mean to be honest with you like i
said i'm a big advocate of them just
kind of like legalizing and regulating
yeah they should have never made that
[ __ ] illegal to begin with it should
have controlled all that i mean that's
what's causing all of that right
atrocity
is because of that i mean because
there's a lot of money to be made there
yeah you know the
a lot of [ __ ] the black budget of the
united states comes from that the
[ __ ] the intelligence agencies have
been involved in that i used to not
believe that but then the more i [ __ ]
found out i was like oh i guess they are
they made that [ __ ] illegal back uh or
made it real they increased the
penalties a lot during the war on drugs
during the very early 80s on purpose
because the ruling class wanted to get
involved in it if you made it legal all
the money would vanish they wanted that
money
hell yeah i'm not saying not everybody
in the ruling class if there were
certain people in the really classical
oh this is a good idea because they
wanted prohibition back
yeah they made a lot of money here in
prohibition era
people didn't want to get alcohol to get
rid of alcohol they wanted alcohol to be
highly profitable the only way to make
alcohol highly profitable is to make it
illegal then it becomes real profitable
that's why illegalizing drug guns is
ridiculous
in brazil basically all civilian firearm
ownership is is banned it's illegal you
can't even get the ammunition
so what does that mean it means it's
every [ __ ] ware everywhere
the [ __ ] organized crime cartels make
guns they can make ammo and they bring
that stuff into brazil
and and this shit's worth a lot of money
every criminal cartel has a [ __ ] ton of
guns every civilian defense militia has
a whole bunch of guns and and who sold
them that guns the same ruling class
that made him illegal
yes
difficult to accept but sad but true the
same rich people that banned those guns
is making a killing off of smuggling
them into their own country
because they love that they're it's
about money they don't give a [ __ ] about
you they hate you it and it's been that
way in brazil i grew up there
the ruling class gives a [ __ ] about the
peasants it's about how much money are
we gonna make off these [ __ ] suckers
it's bad it's bad
and they they the entire system is
rigged they own all the [ __ ] media
they own all the political parties and
political parties in brazil just kind of
pop up like popcorn they're little bitty
things they're little startups and they
can buy influence in any of them because
they're all poor people
you know it's easy to bribe poor people
or it's just a he's a poor guy with a
doctorate maybe but you can still bribe
them
bribery is what runs
brazil it's kind of like the mirror
universe out of [ __ ] star trek it's
exactly like that
i love brazil though i like to had a
good time there it's chaotic as [ __ ] i
was from some lit grub partially in sao
paulo
and i was just kind of built for that in
a certain way
but i always had a [ __ ]
firewall i never thought america was
like that but as i got older and more
things got unveiled over time the way it
really was stripping away the varnish
over it i realized now brazil america's
exactly the same way it was just better
at hiding it
and it's become more and more apparent
rich people are like criminals or they
are criminals they have a lot of the
same tastes in things
and i'm not talking about just random
rich peoples in nice houses not them
they're servants i'm talking about
oligarch class you know
multi-billionaires they're [ __ ]
crooks
you can't
make that much money without being a
crook it just
kind of goes hand in hand
there's a reason why you rose to the top
somebody asked if anybody had seen those
fear street movies i haven't seen them
but i heard like the first one was good
but
that's all i've heard
i don't really know
i haven't watched them
but
i've seen some good i've seen some good
um
i've seen some good horror movies lately
though
i mean we talked about the new david
cronenberg one we still haven't like
gone we still haven't seen that [ __ ]
top gun movie we still haven't seen
i wanted to see that new a24 movie i
think that new blumhouse movie is
starting
uh the black phone i kind of wanted to
see that that looks kind of good
murder says elon's probably a big coke
head yeah he heard his coconut oh it
doesn't surprise me
that wouldn't surprise me
um
when we were kids you know i don't know
how young these people are you know
[ __ ] coke was always uh
the the drug of rich guys
yeah that was expensive well they were
the only ones that could afford it yeah
yeah it was expensive and well then [ __ ]
they made whole movies about that [ __ ]
yeah bright lights big city wasn't a
bright light big city and that other one
that was all yeah all the yet like
yuppies that were all right [ __ ]
yeah just because you like blow doesn't
make you a criminal
but
to deal in that would make you a
criminal
but when you're talking about people of
such high
order they own the law and the criminal
justice system and they're
you know they're basically kind of like
royal families they do whatever they
want laws don't apply to them they just
apply to you
you know
that's the way it is
gets more ice
i'm out of vodka am i not you're out of
vodka you want some uh want some of this
instead no okay then that's it you're
[ __ ]
no more vodka for you there's no other
alcohol in the house of tequila oh okay
i don't want to see it when you watch
tequila oh you got any you got any like
ginger ale or anything no you don't get
anything
diet dr pepper i got that
oh all right i wouldn't mind some of
that okay
like i said i don't really i just want
something to drink it doesn't have to be
alcoholic
because i'm just thirsty you know what
i'm saying
because we drank glass and i didn't
drink a [ __ ] i didn't drink a [ __ ] ton
last night but
i didn't really want to drink like more
again because
dj manix is heading out now see you guys
later okay have a have a good time
safe journey and all that less than zero
that was the one that i was thinking of
is even is bright light's big city even
about drugs that was a yuppie movie too
right i gotta i get them all confused
but less than zero was actually the one
that i was thinking of
i've been meaning to read that book
actually i've never read it
i saw the movie like a long time ago but
you know what i mean
uh john gore said abel ferreira's fierce
city is good i don't think i've ever
seen that i've seen like so i've seen
abel ferreira's other stuff like i saw
well i saw like his old ones like miz 45
and driller killer and all that
but i don't think i've seen that one
i'll have to like watch that
hey zach just arrived hey guys me and my
boyfriend finn are watching the show
well hey
welcome to the show
we've already been here an hour and 40
minutes we're kind of tired because we
were out like late last night but we're
trying to we're trying to keep it
together i'm out of booze though
i only had enough i only had enough for
one
drink so now i have to just drink soda
look at you guys can't see but like
pookie is like right there and she's
just like laying right there with her
little mouse of life she has like a
little mouse like potato paws
what you doing baby yeah oh and she's
sitting on the other mouth somebody was
mentioning there's a tom cruise movie
where he was smuggling drugs for the cia
really that's what he said
yeah if that movie exists go ahead and
drop that in the comments section i
don't mind seeing that so that's diet dr
pepper yeah it's pretty good that's not
bad it's pretty good
doesn't taste that different well it
tastes a little bit different
than regular one of the best
the diet dr pepper and diet diet root
beer is good
diet [ __ ] coke is not good well i
don't even like coke all that now coke
zero and all that other [ __ ] that's a
lot better
but
camp guys said they had a vodka on sale
for 11 bucks today at the liquor store
holy crap next dimension says american
made tom cruise okay american made oh
louie's on there
louis says that too
all right all right or not all right
hernandez you send me that one i'll
review it
i'm gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] myself out like
that we still got to do we did the first
godfather but we still gotta we still
gotta do
two and three two three maybe we should
do that well okay like we gotta tomorrow
we're gonna talk about last duel yes we
watched that was good and then we wanted
to watch mad god yeah on shutter so we
gotta talk about that and then maybe
we'll do godfather too like this week
that okay if y'all haven't seen last
duel go ahead and see it that's good we
streamed it
um
okay almost no we didn't no we didn't we
just oh that's right that's right
we have it on how many together yeah
that's right we had it on so i bought it
but i think you can stream it in it
you should think you can but this time
but we yeah we got the what was the one
where we tried to stream it it wasn't
out yet
ghostbusters after late ghostbusters you
can buy it but you can't rent it yeah i
wanted to see what that was all about it
wasn't that expensive to buy but it's
like i would rather kind of like watch
it first before i bought it you know
what i'm saying yeah
but
um i don't think i don't think oscar is
here but i wanted to tell him because he
kept bugging me about watching x the new
ty west movie i finally i finally
watched it okay so the review of it is
going up on the 23rd the 23rd so it's
gone up on thursday i already recorded
it it was really good i liked it a lot
but i finally got around to watching it
because the price went down i wasn't
gonna pay 20 bucks to see it because i
missed it in the theater yeah but it
came down to like five dollars so i said
okay i'll watch it now say hernandez is
is it good is is american-made is it
good
i have heard it brought up before but i
just hadn't i didn't even realize that
it was a tom cruise movie
i'm telling you man tom cruise did have
some does have some good movies and we
still haven't seen [ __ ] top gun yet
that's what i was gonna say you know
what's weird i think that either last
night or the night before
i think i dreamed that we went and saw
it and i got motion sickness yeah
from the airplane shots i was like yeah
that sounds about right hernandez says
it's good okay what year was that
hmm
i didn't know about it i didn't like i
like i said i heard of it but i didn't
know that tom cruise was in it i was
like i was talking to i was talking to
jen last night because she's always
asking me like oh what good horror
movies have you seen lately because i've
always seen a bunch
and
i was saying to her i was like dude
every time i go and look like on because
i have so many [ __ ] streaming
services now and i was just like oh i
want to see that ooh i want to see that
it's like it's i can't keep up
there's still like a bunch of old [ __ ]
that i still want to see that you know
that that i still need to like talk
about and stuff but then they keep
putting out new stuff and i'm just kind
of like oh man that looks good too oh
[ __ ] i'm never going to live long enough
to see all these [ __ ] movies and like
all the books that i want to read too
it just it just makes me sad like every
time i go to
like to be or hbo max or something like
that and i'm scrolling through the
horror movies and i'm just like oh man
oh i wanted to see that oh i wanted to
see that zack says his favorite tom
cruise movies his eyes wide shut and
rain man i'm gonna say those are both
good movies i like them both uh but no
[ __ ] tom has some better better ones
that collateral if i let louie sent me
was real good
um where he plays
an assassin
also um
the
his spy series mission impossible
the first couple ones are kind of cheesy
but they're movies of their time
but like the last two or three
mission impossibles were [ __ ] great
real good yeah they got better as they
went on because i saw like
i didn't see the first ones when they
came out but like you were sho you had
them all so you were showing them to me
and i was like these first ones i'm like
these are kind of goofy i saw them when
they came out they were more like the
old tv show yeah when i saw them when
they first came out and they were movies
of their time
the second one was a john woo movie
which was that was real hip in the day
yeah you know what i mean it had that
kung fu kind of feel to it which i was
that was really cool in those days but
um after
after um
uh double 07 casino royale came out yeah
then everybody had to be yeah they're
like so possible was gonna have to
[ __ ] keep up with that that was that
was like a mic drop yeah yeah i know
zach likes [ __ ] um double seb the new
double-oh-seven
you would like
[ __ ] um
the the last like two or three mission
impossibles yeah what were they fallout
ghost protocol
gross protocol and i think there's
another one i can't remember what the
other one's gone they're they're good
they're real good just like just and he
plays a dude he's kind of like ethan
hutt is a bond
kind of like is a bond-like character
but it's a little more realistic than
james bond
even though i'm not gonna say james bond
isn't realistic
it kind of isn't it kind of depends on
which story you're talking about
james bond is always working in the
shadows he's caught basically on his own
um which i guess you could do that
um
spy work has never been that exciting
okay
that's what i was thinking but you know
nobody wants to see movies about real
people doing their real jobs because
that would be like boring as [ __ ] i
would think
the closest thing to really james bond
in the real world [ __ ] intelligence
old school intelligence stuff would have
been female sex operatives
they were pretty much worked alone
but they weren't killing people [ __ ]
kind of have to yeah they were [ __ ]
dudes but they weren't killed killing
did
uh
they may have killed themselves so they
may have killed it although they
probably could have killed a dude if
they really wanted them to like they
could just give them some poison or
something it wasn't their mission though
their mission was to get dirt on a guy
and to convert him into getting rogue
nation yeah that's right
that was the other you should see you
should zach you should see um
some of the mission impossibles the
later ones they're good you'll like them
in mission impossible
ethan hunt is a part of a team
okay which makes it a lot more plausible
you can't do all that [ __ ] on your own
you gotta [ __ ] have a team backing
you up
doing all different kinds of support for
you
delivering you places and making stuff
for you and talking to you and giving
you things over the [ __ ] over your
ear pieces and [ __ ] and usually mission
impossible is about breaking into a
place
and getting something and then getting
out of there usually something along
that line yeah it's an impossible it's
an impossible [ __ ] task that's kind
of the whole point of this area he's
gonna be there
doing it on his own but there's a whole
crew of guys
[ __ ] helping him
now ethan hunt's [ __ ] main backup
dude is i don't remember the name of his
character or the name of the damn actor
but he was
the black dude
from
not pulp fiction yeah was it pulp
fiction
he was the gangster that got [ __ ] up
to ass by the [ __ ] rednecks
yeah because i'm going to take missile
rapists here to blow torch that guy
plays
yeah that's a [ __ ] i like that that's
right i forgot that's real he's got that
real [ __ ] tough voice and [ __ ] he's
in him and he's kind of
um ethan hunt's [ __ ] kind of like
main support guy who makes sure that he
gets there on time and then everything's
and and he's just kind of a
brilliant support
guy and they're like best friends and
evidently i never saw the television
program
you may have seen only a couple of
episodes when i was a kid but i don't
remember much about it and i think there
was a black guy in the television
program
it was kind of like here's another one
that i want to see they say you can get
all of the wild wild west on dvd for
pretty cheap
with adam west yeah you ever seen that
one ving rhames that's that guy's name
ding rhames that's right reigns yeah he
does a great job in the movies that i
saw
yeah i'm gonna go back and watch all
those my memory isn't what it was after
these head injuries i just remember what
i [ __ ] i forget people's names but i
never remember never never forget faces
and [ __ ]
or or i'll remember everything i told
you or said to you but i won't be able
to remember your name i'll forget
jenny's name
[Laughter]
i'd be like
hey jenny hey
and it's it's not
it's you know
after getting your [ __ ] brains bashed
in
there's residual [ __ ]
[Laughter]
residual shit'll [ __ ] with you but um
yeah see those zack
you'll like them
the the first two
they're not
they're out of style okay the way
they're filmed or out of style but
they're still worth seeing they're kind
of more like the old tv show it used to
be that's what they were but that was
okay back then because that's kind of
more what they were doing yeah i saw
them when they came out and liked them
but after they went like in the more
like gritty yeah action directions says
vodka soon as soon as casino royale came
out yeah everybody's like oh well we
have to do that yeah and that's what
they did
um
yeah hugo says the jack reacher series
yeah i've heard those are good too i
think i read a couple of the books like
a long time ago you probably like like i
would like i don't think i've seen the
movies but like i said i read i've read
a couple of the jack reacher books i
gotta get up on all that stuff man i'm
falling behind
that's what i'm saying that's what see
yeah i mean and me i'm just like a
horror movie person and even if you're
just a horror movie person you can't
keep up you can't keep up with this [ __ ]
there's just so much like i was watching
um if you have a shutter like i was
watching shutter like they had the 2022
like uh fangoria like the chainsaw
awards and they were given all the
awards for like all the movies from last
year and i'm like [ __ ] i haven't seen
like hardly any of those holy crap and
so i had to like write them all down and
then i had to like go see them and
you know i i did end up seeing like a
whole bunch of them so i so i did do
that and like reveal it
i forgot about that yeah i saw that i
remember the book's good i saw um
trailers for it on other dvds that i was
blu-rays i was watching so that looks
pretty good but i haven't seen them i
haven't seen one of them
yeah somebody said the the movie they
were talking about earlier american made
yeah next dimension media said um you
were talking about cocaine cowboys
american made is about the pilot they
talked about in that documentary okay
very seal okay but that's what it's
about okay so you'd probably be into
that yeah
because we just saw cocaine cowboys on a
while ago actually just like a few
months ago yeah [ __ ]
that's a trip that they were using
shortwave radio to [ __ ] call
nicaragua and colombia and all these
[ __ ] places down in central america
to get those air strips ready to bring
the cocaine over
hey we're bringing the cocaine bringing
it over
[Laughter]
we were talking about you know
radio communications on the show a
couple days back i was pulling out all
my radios yeah because we were talking
about the nominal code talker yeah you
could talk about the navajo code talkers
and how all that shit's obsolete because
now you have [ __ ] compressed and
scrambled radio communications and then
you can also do stuff over online
community online communication is
[ __ ]
super secure as long as somebody's not
on you you just have to know how to do
it you know you had guys that were given
[ __ ]
sensitive and secret information
over live chat inside of video games
because
what counter intelligence agent would be
[ __ ] looking
trying to catch dudes talking to each
other over xboxes
you know playing halo it's just not
going to happen
that's all gone
that's all gone and then you have to
have the ability to
to keep an eye on somebody and
consistently be able to eavesdrop on
them on them through all these different
platforms
so a lot of [ __ ] like
code talking
and
uh [ __ ] radio uh what do you call
them
number stations and things it's all
obsolete don't need it anymore
let's see what everybody's talking about
yeah ving rhames
somebody says watch spy hard hugo says
that i don't know what spy heart is
yeah cam guy says that the bond music
was top notch as well the thing is
and i'm a big uh
fan of uh the new james bond series
not all of the theme songs were good
only the first two were if you ask me
the casino royale theme song was good
and um
what was the other one
quantum of solace
it had a good theme song too the other
ones
i didn't think theme songs were any good
they just didn't have that
bond grass
with the [ __ ]
almost kind of an over-the-top optimism
you know
in a way well they were kind of dark but
optimistic at the same time but the
other ones were too slow and two
falsetto
male vocals and i just
they weren't bad they just didn't stand
out as a bond theme to me
you know
when you go back to go back through time
some of those bond themes they were just
[ __ ] badass
living daylights from aha [ __ ] that
was a badass one uh
garbage did one the world is not enough
i mean that's a [ __ ] bond
theme
[ __ ] a view to a kill from duran
duran i still love that song
i mean i love duran duran anyway but
that was that that was a great bomb
great theme song
bond movies usually had great theme
songs
yeah that's kind of like part of the
brand that was it
but i'd have to say
those last three double-oh-seven movies
that the i think was three right so you
had spectre
um
spectre and uh hold on you hit your head
[ __ ]
casino royale quantum solace
um
skyfall skyfall skyfall didn't have a
great theme song and then you had
spectre not great really
the theme song and then the last one was
uh what was the name of that movie
no time to do that no time to die that
theme song also didn't stand out those
last three themes i watched this guy
fall then
no i didn't
it was okay but it just didn't
it just didn't have it didn't sound like
a james bond theme song to me
just didn't
danny rowling says timothy dalton and
pierce brosnan are the best bonds in my
opinion
uh yeah
i got to go back and see uh timothy
dalton once i think he made two
was he in two or three i think he was
only in two
i saw him in the theater when i was a
kid i saw him in the theater in brazil
and was impressed with them at the time
i remember thinking that they were real
gritty
and kind of hardcore for the time well
for the time they were because prior to
that you had roger moore which is kind
of like cheesy kind of cheesy although i
liked roger moore kind of but it was it
was almost like comedy or parody i love
it
um
they were excuses to see exotic
locations
in the roger war era yeah it was back
when people didn't have google earth and
[ __ ]
but uh it was kind of like [ __ ]
theatrical [ __ ] tourism you know
you're gonna go see some [ __ ] location
points in some locations yeah
so it's not quite they still do that but
it doesn't have the quite the same
impact as it used to
but um
i gotta go back and look at timothy
dalton once or not uh yeah not timothy
the dog yeah timothy dahl
now do you remember him being kind of
hardcore but i don't know how they'd
stack up against
the new [ __ ] you know probably not well
timothy dalton was in um
flash gordon
yeah
prince uh
yeah it was
all they could think of was the princess
brad prince like [ __ ] he was like
he was like robbie
his name was prince that's right that's
right he was not only was a baron he was
a baron and a prince
he's like prince
prince baron cameron yeah yeah king
emperor
oh my god that's funny
yeah
oh my god john goris is talking about
the license to kill theme song
which was gladys knight yeah i remember
that one i mean there were a lot of
really good there were a lot of good
bond themes on it was uh if
i'm going to ask you guys
like i haven't seen them i haven't seen
the old [ __ ] in a long time was the were
the pierce brosnan movies
were they hardcore were they gritty i
mean
i remember thinking they were but at the
time i was
15
maybe
13 to 15 13 15 16 around that time so
uh you know and it might just be all
relative because like i said now now
that everything is like you know
grittier super everything has to be
super gritty and grim nowadays and
realistic and stuff yeah but it wasn't
like that back then right everything was
still kind of probably did they
they probably don't hold up you probably
see it now and it's just probably
mediocre
yeah it might be one of those things
where they're just kind of like a
product of their time i mean you know i
think they can still be enjoyed
just as movies but
i don't know some things i think it's
better if you see it at the time
because especially something like that
like after the after the
recent bonds came out the daniel craig
ones
you know
i don't think the ones from the 90s or
anything like that are gonna look all
that gritty anymore
said no they were ridiculous
[Laughter]
yeah he said he never liked it timothy
dalton in it
i just i don't really i can't really
have an opinion on it because i don't
even remember if i've seen a single
timothy dalton one all the way through
i'm sure i've seen like scenes from them
and stuff
in those days the dalton ones were like
a departure
from
it was normal in james bond
and i was like oh man this is a lot
better
you know i liked him
but like i said
i saw him in the theater when they came
out as a kid and never saw him again so
my memory might be totally [ __ ] up it
was just the impression we had at the
time
i remember other people liking it
but like i said times change
well that's kind of why i like to
revisit
things like stuff that i really liked
when i was younger it's like sometimes i
like to watch it when i was older just
to see well because i'm always kind of
curious too it's like what was it that i
liked so much about this yeah you know
what i mean like when i was younger like
what appealed to me like if i don't like
it now like what's the difference
john gore said i like the bond film
where his bride gets whacked in a
drive-by at the end
which one was that
isabella two fell says the part where
felix gets chewed up by a shark and then
they deliver him back to bond is pretty
gruesome he's still alive
he was chewed up by a shark but still
alive yikes
yeah i didn't see that what movie was
that from
yeah i don't know
what's what parts of him did the st did
the shark chew on yeah
not his head obviously
bundy dana said i remember the jaws guy
and not the shark obviously uh in the
bond movies and sauce saucer they could
chop his head off yeah that was like one
of the one of the enduring memories i
had of like
that cable
yeah
that was uh richard keel that guy yeah
because he was also an eaga
he was in all those like cheesy and
human duplicators and like all those
shitty b movies that were on uh msd
because he was like a big [ __ ] giant
dude now i remember some of the you know
roger moore
bond movies
as a kid i liked him
yeah i did too yeah i remember uh
[ __ ] diamonds are forever but we
didn't know any better yeah
and i haven't seen them since then but
diamonds are forever remember that that
guy get
they threw that guy in that pipe and
then they sealed him inside and then
they then they took the pipe put it
inside the pipeline and he woke up that
was actually bond in the pipe
they knocked him in the pipe and he woke
up he's in there they sent something
down the pipe and he jumped on top of it
it was something i guess inspecting the
damn welds
a robot
um i just remember that part of it
although i have to say that even when i
was younger i i think even then i
understood that moonraker was stupid as
[ __ ] yeah i remember i saw moonraker
i saw it moonraker and even as a kid i
[ __ ] liked it
i want to go back and see what that was
about it's probably ridiculous um
which one was the one where they had the
sharks in the swimming pool i don't
remember them yeah yeah did they have
sharks in the swimming pool like like
that [ __ ] would open and like the sharks
to swim out this one that like scared
the [ __ ] out of me because i was always
like so for a long time after i was
scared to swim at a swimming pool
because i thought like a super villain
was gonna like release some [ __ ]
sharks and that was like cheesy 60s
slash 70s stuff
and it and it looked like something out
of a disneyland theme park all the time
like [ __ ] it's a small world
a lot of the
decor round stuff
pools were always inside the house
they're around
and just
weird interiors i always kind of wanted
to stucco type stuff i thought that
would be so cool
but i don't really i've never really i
don't really remember seeing any of the
[ __ ] old james bonds i remember some
of the [ __ ] where roger moore was so old
that it was not credible and he's
getting in type in inside these little
damn mini jets and flying them around
and [ __ ]
he's like
wowing an amazing [ __ ] [ __ ] 22
year old women that want to jump his
[ __ ] 65 year old ass
and there's nothing two years so hot
i'll get the medal yeah
he takes his shirt off and he's like a
skeleton
he's like a skeleton
skinny and [ __ ] you know what i mean
[ __ ] with like nasty [ __ ] chest
hairs and [ __ ]
like the women love this [ __ ]
i'm going like i don't know hopefully
those actresses got hazard that was back
when people people could suspend
disbelief you know when they believed
that the world was really like that
although it may have really been like
that maybe that's why old guys like
those movies so much yeah because
they're like yeah that could totally
that could totally happen but maybe that
maybe somebody my daughter's age or my
granddaughter's age is totally into me
maybe that did happen though
back then because maybe it was more
about money and status and [ __ ] you
know because
oh and you look at china
old fat guys in china are considered to
be [ __ ] wealthy and powerful and
they're like the sex symbols
do you realize that in north korea they
think the sexiest [ __ ] alive is
kim jong-un
they put they have those defector women
they'd bring them back and they would be
laughing over what they thought was
[ __ ] sexy they liked kim jong-un
because he was fat they didn't see fat
guys
so therefore he thinks well yeah because
everyone's starving everyone's [ __ ]
starving that's [ __ ] up so they
thought he was [ __ ] sexy as hell that
was the [ __ ] best-looking man in the
world
because he was fat
and they just that was just something
that was actually eating and yeah he has
money to buy food you just listen to
some of those defectors
there are stories of how how their
how the situation will change your
perception on reality
and um
young korean women were
raised from an early age to want to go
out with [ __ ] old fat guys
old fat guys because they had all the
food
and all the money and that all the women
were competing for they were clearly
eating all the food they were eating
and when they are in a society where
they don't have anything and all the
[ __ ] women that are better looking
than them or competing for those guys
they think that that's the [ __ ] that's a
catch
ain't that something
i always you know going back to roger
moore i always thought that he looked
very leathery
yeah do you think he looked yeah like
he'd been in a tanning salon
he looked a little bit like a like a
like a puppy's chew toy yes lately
you know
that and i mean no offense meant i'm
just saying he did kind of look like
that like yeah he looked like he'd been
out in the sun thunder con's pulling out
george lassenby he said he wasn't bad
involved either he liked the movie her
magic secret service i think
he was just in one yeah he was just that
one i've heard about those other movies
but i mostly didn't i don't think i saw
the george ladies and beyond i've seen
him in other movies but i don't think
i've seen his bond movie unless i pr i
might have seen it as a kid because i
saw a lot of bond movies when i was a
kid yeah [ __ ] now khan's talking
about the jaws and moonraker yeah what
the deal was is that jaws had these damn
artificial teeth or they were artificial
jaws
and he he was the the one of the bond
enforcers super villains and
there was a scene where he bites through
[ __ ]
a cable to a cable car if i remember
correctly
and in the end though
he ends up switching sides becoming a
good guy that the bad guys were just
using him
and he runs off with some cutie pie
chicken [ __ ] daisy dukes and [ __ ]
uh
long braids coming out her head like
[ __ ] wendy from wendy's burgers
that's what she looking for that's the
dessert
and she looks at him and smiles and
she's got braces that's right
everybody's like yeah and he picks her
up and they run out there to live
happily ever after
yeah i mean braces are hardly the same
as like entire metal teeth and all i was
thinking just now was can he like are
they like dentures can he take them out
no i think they were metal jaws because
um like i'm
not to be indelicate but i mean when he
goes down on her they maybe are gonna
have a problem
if i remember correctly it wasn't just
teeth i think his whole upper and lower
jaw were artificial made out of [ __ ]
titanium or something
some kind of exotic metal
to make you a [ __ ] scary bond villain
he wasn't it wasn't a scary he wasn't a
bond villain per se he was a bond
henchman
you know he was the villain's henchman i
just always well i just always remember
him because like i said it's richard
keillon he doesn't have a single
speaking [ __ ] he was in a bunch of other
yeah i don't think he has a speaking
role
did you ever see that movie ego no where
he played a caveman no
it's pretty weird it was on it was on uh
mystery science theater actually yeah
and he was in another one called human
duplicators where he was
where he did was he played a scientist
and they were like
he was well he was an alien i think yeah
he's an alien and they came here and
they were trying to like duplicate
people as the title suggests so how long
we've been streaming
two hours okay
granthar says uh grampher went to us he
still affirmed himself in the third
person that's really funny grandpa went
to a graduation party today in trenton
at the westfield activity center blocked
from steve's old house oh [ __ ] was
tempted to see if the love hotel was
still in operation
i don't think any of them still i don't
even think any of them are in that house
anymore i don't think steve's mom's in
that house anymore i don't think
hmm
i think the house goes i wouldn't know
i've never been there
john gore says uh roger moore was good
in spice world
do you know i've never seen spice world
should i
i mean probably not is it worth watching
probably not i'm kind of thinking well
like i said i'm so behind on my horror
movie watching it's just like all these
other movies that i need to get around
to i'm probably never gonna get around
to
because i'm just not gonna have time i
would love to [ __ ] revisit the old
james bond movies but
i'm not sure i could sit through one we
have to see
you'd have to be in the right mood right
in the right moment yeah
i mean
you know
it's just
i'm so used to the new ones now that i
feel like
i like i like old movies in a lot of
ways but yeah i like old horror movies i
like old like mysteries i like stuff
like that but like action movies and
stuff like that it's just i don't know
it's not quite the same it's just kind
of like comedies yeah like usually when
you watch like an old comedy
usually it's not funny because like
shit's not funny anymore because like
comedy changes now there's some movies
from like the 80s and stuff like that
that i think are still funny like
ghostbusters
i like to revisit in old uh burt
reynolds movies
yeah and we're pretty good yeah
that's true i mean i still liked i don't
yeah i still like smoking the bandit and
all that
that was still white lightning and gator
were pretty fun yeah uh smoking the
bandit was good
and there was i think we saw one and two
right or we just see one
i don't think we saw two no
and there was a three yeah i had
completely forgotten about that well no
because burt reynolds wasn't in it
jerry reed who was in the first one yeah
was in it but he was playing burt
reynolds character i think and i was
just like how does that work
say like switch bodies what the [ __ ]
how'd they explain that i don't know if
i ever saw the third one i'd be very
surprised if i hadn't because it seemed
like it was probably on hbo like every
five minutes like back in the 80s so i
probably watched it we didn't revisit
cannonball run
yeah we still have the trash well
because they made a second one of that
too like remember we were gonna watch it
one night but i think like we couldn't
find it or you had to pay to rent it we
were like ah [ __ ] it there was something
else that was free
cannonball run was supposed to be kind
of like fun for the whole family and it
was like a movie that had everybody in
it which they did that [ __ ] in the 70s a
lot where it's a movie that had some
hollywood stores all hollywood stars
each one of them with a cameo appearance
basically and just where you could just
see everybody it was it was it was
hollywood's version of social media of
the time
well it was almost kind of like the
movie version of uh what was that what
was that thing like circus of the stars
circus of the stars remember how they
would do that every year yeah and you
weren't supposed to take the movie
seriously you weren't even supposed to
take the story seriously
it was just an excuse to sit there and
[ __ ]
see your favorite stars act a fool you
know and say witty [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you had to be there
wouldn't work today
danny rowling said nobody in cannonball
run was funny in my opinion yeah
i know probably not i mean i think i
remember it being funny like when i was
a kid but
i haven't seen it since then no he said
except for jackie chan oh that's right i
forgot jackie chan was in that yeah dom
deluise would jump up
with his [ __ ] mexican luchador
[ __ ] mask on it's captain chaos with
a [ __ ]
bat with a [ __ ] cape
and uh
then you had who else was in that [ __ ]
[ __ ] dean martin was in it right yeah
i think he was it was dean martin d
martin and sammy davis and sammy david
they were in the same car right they
were dressed up like priests yeah in
fact sammy davis was wearing his head of
bath of it around yeah because well he
was the same that and talavei gave him
yeah they didn't mention it but you can
see
i had a bathroom at all yeah he was the
satanic priest yeah and dean martin was
like being his drunk self well he was
being martin he was pretty much drunk
all the time i think he was a bishop
or a bishop or a he was a or a cardinal
anton levan made him a bishop or a
cardinal with it
nice yeah
john gore says spice world's a hoot
good okay i'll watch it one of these
days
danny rowling said used cars is still
funny and holds up with crustal yeah
that's right we should probably watch
that one yeah these days
uh kanavasan says you need to review the
ultra shitty garbage pail kids movie
it's so bad you last laugh your ass off
i've seen scenes from it but i don't
think i've ever sat through the whole
entire thing that's a horror movie i
think in it i don't like a cheating no
that's right i don't think it's a horror
movie is it i thought it was a comedy i
thought it was like a horror comedy like
gremlin because no because it's based on
those [ __ ]
cards my brother had some of those cards
and then grampler says watching spice
world is worse than taking a cheese
grater to your taint
and there's no greater misery than
taking a cheese critter cheat date
oh my god
camp guy said original the matrix taxi
driver fight club and vanilla sky are
three series movies that's four but
whatever uh who's counting uh
serious movies i could get my son to
watch with me when he was like nine to
13 years old oh that's pretty cool
liquid sky vanilla's guy vanilla sky
yeah i remember that one that was that
was a remake that was a no that was a
remake of um open your eyes wasn't it
that spanish movie wasn't tom cruise and
vanilla sky okay well like i said it was
a remake of a spanish what was the one
it was kind of like a punk rock movie
taking place in one of those cities
might be chicago remember that i think i
thought it was liquid sky or vanilla sky
or liquid sky
that one that one we watched oh that was
um what the [ __ ] wasn't even it was
liquid something liquid sky maybe it was
liquids guys it had the dam it didn't
make any damn sense no it didn't it made
no sense and there was a [ __ ] flying
saucer on the roof or something that was
doing [ __ ] the people didn't make any
sense
liquid sky i think is what it was it
says uh cam and i said he also watched
the grifters wow and being john
malkovich as well wow that's awesome
i love being john malkovich that's like
that's a great [ __ ] movie that's a
great [ __ ] movie
it's so [ __ ] weird
you've never seen that have you oh no oh
it's funny
it's basically about
um
it's kind of hard to explain you can
sort of like it's sort of like you can
rent out space inside john malkovich's
head so you can like see the world
through john malkovich's eyes so john
malkovich is in it but he's like playing
himself why would i want to do that but
it's a fictional no it's like funny it's
super funny i mean it's funny in like a
bizarre like black humor kind of way but
yeah i loved that movie so it was so
[ __ ] weird all right so um
kind of awesome said tom do you remember
a movie called hot dog the motion
picture i remember that was funny no i
vaguely remember that i probably saw it
once
what you know what they added the other
day to
amazon or something was uh cannibal
women in the avocado jungle of death
yeah which that was that's kind of like
an anthology comedy type type of movie
it's kind of like kentucky fried movie
that kind of stuff did we even get any
super chats today i'm gonna have to come
down i'm gonna have to i'm gonna crack
my whip on these people come down on
these people he's bringing out a single
goddamn super chat shame on you you free
loaders
[Laughter]
zack
zack usually sent us money not even zach
[ __ ] jumped in where the hell is that
tom's gonna cry i'm gonna start crying
okay so uh conor hatson said yeah liquid
skies from 1982. yeah we watched guys
sucked man it was um interesting
uh we watched that on december
yeah i mean it was mostly just about
like weird punk rockers like hanging out
and then oh by the way there's like an
alien there's aliens and they're doing
something that doesn't have anything to
do with anything
yeah
we were kind of like all right i don't
know why that movie was put together
that way it seemed like just probably
like a lot of friends yeah and maybe and
maybe they were all kind of on heroin
and uh
the one okay there were two of them
there were two movies in the history of
[ __ ] cinema
that [ __ ] me over bad oh i can't wait
to hear this i remembered him being good
until i saw him again whoa whoa whoa
money coming oh boy like look at that
next dimension came in and sent me 10
bucks thank you very much
good this we're going to talk [ __ ] thank
you we got to get this [ __ ] paced on
sounds like [ __ ] [ __ ] laid out 700
bucks for air conditioning [ __ ]
700 bucks for [ __ ] well they were
freezing up they had to like come and
like get they had to come and melt it
all and like get it all cleaned and just
yeah this is the first year i'm running
these [ __ ] air conditioners since we
bought this house and i don't know how
long they've been maintained they need
to be recharged well yeah because they
were renting it out to people like
before so i don't know when the last
time we got two central systems one for
upstairs and one for downstairs in this
thing so
700 i thought it was only gonna be like
300. right and then they came back well
you got two units and i was like oh yeah
i [ __ ] forgot i got
but anyway
the two movies that really [ __ ] me
over hold on i'm going to sneeze
that's not one of the movies i remember
them being great until i saw him
again
since i grew up
one
scanner's two
yeah i saw scanners in love that saw
scanners too and i was like man this
[ __ ] [ __ ] sucks i couldn't get
through 10 minutes of [ __ ] scanners
too that's how bad that [ __ ] was
and then the other one that really
[ __ ] got me
was [ __ ] transfers
oh i knew you were gonna say that i knew
you're gonna die i thought transfers i
thought transfers was good from how i
remembered it and then i [ __ ]
bought transfers on blu-ray
the first five minutes was good the rest
of that [ __ ] movie was like what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] it was like something
somebody made at home you're like
and here's the funny thing there's like
six of those
yeah that's all that dude [ __ ] is like
watching them that's all i do does is
make [ __ ]
smoothie
moves he's like this is a really good
idea god damn it one of these days i'm
gonna get a billion dollars for this it
was a good idea but yeah it was they
couldn't execute it
time travel through your genetic lines
you could
inject something into yourself and you
would wake up in one of your ancestors
or descendants is that's right i forgot
descendants that is actually that is a
good idea actually you could travel
through time through the genetic lines
but you need more time you need more
time money and talent uh yeah to kind of
like convey that yeah once they did once
the story got rolling he's just it's
just about an old guy hanging out with a
hot young chick nothing happens he's
trying to get laid
and he's supposed to be we can just go
to the bar and see yeah and he's
supposed to be like
he's supposed to be like a detective
like [ __ ] blade runner
well the funny thing about that is that
i had never seen transfers and you like
really talked it up to me
i'm gonna buy it oh i saw it a long time
ago it was so good and then like we're
watching and i'm like
yeah and i couldn't get i'm like are you
all right this is really not a good
movie yeah
i was like 20 minutes into it it's like
is this even the movie that you were
that you were thinking of well because
sometimes you have a thing where yeah
where you're thinking of a completely
different movie because i've had you do
that a couple of times you're like oh
this movie that was called this and blah
blah happened i'm like that's not
raptors knows what i'm talking about
back when we were going to high school
in michigan because i did part of my
high school in michigan part of in
brazil
when i was in michigan [ __ ] i was
hanging out with grafters and some other
dudes i was [ __ ] hanging out
with at this time
me and mike kowalski i don't remember
mike kowalski but me and mike kowalski
and [ __ ] a friend of ours from
woodhaven
named derek hardik
his last name which it was h-a-r-d-i-c-k
heartick hard dick hard dick and he
would call himself derek hard dick to
girls and then he'd pull that [ __ ] out
of his pocket that's my name that's my
porn name
he was [ __ ] hilarious all right i
mean if you got a name like that you
might as well just like derek
we rented
[ __ ] transfers
and walked away from the experience like
we saw a [ __ ] masterpiece
that's what we're doing what substances
were you on at the time i don't [ __ ]
know man i don't know what it was he's
like something but i don't remember
i think what really happened
is that we watched the first 10 or 15
minutes of the movie and then started
[ __ ] off and and and and
talking [ __ ] to each other over and not
didn't really pay attention to the movie
and then you only remembered like the
good bit yeah and then afterwards only
[ __ ]
only [ __ ] talked about the best parts
of the movie
i think that happens a lot yeah i think
that's what happened especially if
there's movies that you saw when you
were young like
during your formative years when you're
in a group
yeah and it was just more like the
experience of writing like you know
imagine if you could do that well and
plus it was a good experience because
you were hanging out with your friends
yeah you were having a good time maybe
you were having like a couple beers we
were down in the bacon in mike's
basement in his [ __ ] lounge all right
and we probably were drinking
we're smoking weed
that's what i'm saying or both yeah
and i think and i think i think we were
mostly talked about the movie right
about so you're just you wrote a better
movie in your yeah
[Laughter]
okay this is probably what happened and
then years later
i didn't remember the movie
i remember talking about the movie yeah
i think that's what happened probably
and partying
when the movie was happening right so it
was all part of like a positive
experience yeah yeah yeah and then when
you saw it again like just in regular
movie you're like this is it
because [ __ ] like for days after we
would [ __ ] be like [ __ ] oh you
know i'm shooting up i'm going into my
to it you know ancest i mean
because the dude's name was jack death
and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] we were like yeah my name is
tom death
and we get [ __ ] around like that you
know
because we because it was michigan so we
had overcoats
you know put the overcoat on put a hat
on you know what i mean [ __ ] like
there's something out of blade runner
i think that's what happened
probably i think that's what happened
because then we go to 7-eleven and play
[ __ ] video games play gauntlet yeah
and [ __ ]
spy hunter
and rastan that's when you got butthork
working on a [ __ ]
rest now if you guys know what i'm
talking about is the k
rastan was a video game like conan you
had it was like ghosts and goblins had
to run and jump and [ __ ] throwing
axes and [ __ ] he had axe
and there were these little pits that
had spikes and at one time my friend
jason quinlan
missed the jump and fell down in the pit
and his ass landed right on one of those
spikes
[Laughter]
and when the character died
they disintegrate
and jason goes i got butt worked
i said yeah it went right up your ass
and then on out if anything went up in
your ass we called it god butthorn
it's just crazy it is a very good
descriptive term
[Laughter]
which is probably that approximates the
noise that somebody would probably make
if like a big spike went up their butt
up like it sort of looked like that's
what it looked like
and
[ __ ] teenage boys just come up with
[ __ ] and in their formative years and it
would stick in your head yeah and you'd
use that again i got you [ __ ]
got horked you know what i mean
and we're referring to something happen
in a video game two years earlier yeah
you know well i think kind of like all
kind of groups of friends have that i
mean like you know it was the same like
when i was in junior high and it was
crazy
like we would yeah we would like uh you
know we had we had a lot of kind of like
words that we made up yeah
or that we got from movies or something
like that yeah man it'd be so it'd be on
during the summer when school was out
and we'd go up i'd go to mike's house
and [ __ ]
just sleep in the basement with him
because he didn't have to go home and
i'm gonna hang out with mike
we'd wake up at like 3 30 in the [ __ ]
morning
and go to 7-eleven his 7-eleven was
right behind his house he used to work
at 7-eleven part-time okay
and uh we go down here and play ghosts
and goblins at like 3 30 in the [ __ ]
morning
it's just
something that that sounds funny
teenagers boys have did playing ghosts
and guys like we were getting away with
some [ __ ] well yeah well when you're a
kid yeah it's like i'm gonna go to
7-eleven yeah 3 30 tomorrow i'm going to
get a big gulp and i'm going to go
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
and we were [ __ ] had cigarettes we
were already smoking at that time
smoking
that sounds like and then mike says i
got a shift i got to start my shift in a
couple hours this is what i'm gonna do
okay
there's a [ __ ]
there's a 12 pack of beer in there
that's [ __ ] up i'm gonna throw it out
when i throw that [ __ ] 12 pack of
beer out you go back in there and get it
take it to my house
[Laughter]
it's all right yeah and he goes yeah
it's all [ __ ] up a couple of cans are
crunched and i [ __ ] i'm gonna throw
this [ __ ] out okay go get it later on i
said all right so that [ __ ] be back
there [ __ ] hey free beer stacking up
beer
you guys say
he throw out and i [ __ ] and it's
gonna be in a big paper bag you'll see
it and i'll [ __ ] pull the paper back
out [ __ ] take it back to his house
and [ __ ] throw this [ __ ] out
start stacking the beer up and look
there'll be two packs of cigarettes in
there too
like oh okay all right
okay
like oh my god the mother lode yeah some
people are uh bringing up subspecies
yeah i've actually been wanting to do
because i think shutter added um
at least the first couple sub-species
movies like not too long ago and i've
been putting them in the poll but they
haven't won yet but one of these days
we'll get around to like because yeah i
really like the first sub species i
don't think i've seen any of the other
ones but the first one's really good
uh john gora says strangely i love all
the old movies from my childhood decades
later even more so honestly i like most
of the ones from back then uh at least
most of the ones that i saw like a bunch
of times when i was growing up and
that kind of but you know a lot of those
like um they still hold up every now and
then i see something that doesn't like
but it's usually like comedies and stuff
like that like stuff i thought was funny
back then and like now it's not funny
but
you know most of them most of them i
think did did hold up i mean you know
like [ __ ] that i was when i was a kid uh
john gore said memes were localized back
then oh yeah definitely definitely
and
yeah i can't even remember i'm trying to
remember like some specific examples i
know that we used to
we were all kind of like me and me and
people i knew we were all kind of into
like you know weird ass like indie
movies and stuff so we would always use
like we would always like quote movies
and [ __ ] at each other all the time and
like a lot of [ __ ] from music like song
lyrics and stuff but we like make up
words and stuff too
um
hamburger the motion picture in 1986 was
also funny i vaguely remember that one
too i pretty much i probably saw it but
i don't really remember
that much of anything about it
um
yeah they're talking about yeah
subspecies yeah that's right it was
filmed in romania yeah that was like a
big deal at the time because they're
like hey that's where the actual
vampires are from you know what i mean
um
glenn little said had the soundtrack to
liquid sky like watching the small bus
collide into a train so bad but couldn't
look away
yeah i mean
like i said i don't think i don't think
it's on shutter anymore but they added
it and i was like oh i like any kind of
movie about like punk rock stuff like
from that era so we watched it it's like
it was okay it was just like mostly it
was just kind of boring
you know hold on let me get those more
icing
you didn't even put any ice in my soda
oh i didn't i thought you didn't like
icing so
what are you talking about i like ice
and everything i'm okay
what the hell
i'm not i'm not european over here not
putting ice in things
we put ice in everything i put ice in
everything
i even put ice in milk i know that's
like super gross
all the subspecies are good says danny
rowling except for the last one which
doesn't have radio in it but it's kind
of growing on me nowadays just saying
i'll one of these days we should
probably like watch the whole series
because i've for sure only seen the
first one i've seen the first one a
couple of times and i remember liking it
but i don't think i've seen any other
ones
huh
i don't know how to tell that's time
when he gets back
about the backpacking in the smoky
mountains
uh jenny have you done night breed you
know what i don't think we have yet um i
was thinking about putting in the poll
this week but i don't think i did but
maybe i'll put it in the poll next week
i put it in the poll before but it
didn't win i've seen it a bunch of times
but
yeah hugo said i watched conan in the
theater with friends we still say krom
from time to time yeah well i mean i
yeah i do that as well
is that you
oh okay
i wasn't sure like where you're at no
we're here
grantham said uh grantham went
backpacking in the smoky mountains with
mikey once dude smoked two packs of
winston's a day but could still hump 50
pounds in his backpack count sterling
yeah
yeah to be young yeah mike what's the
[ __ ]
yeah me and uh you also remember
jason jason quinlan
jason quinlan ended up becoming like a
[ __ ] a figure a grand figure in
academia in like university of michigan
for all that damn weird social studies
[ __ ]
super smart guys like
kind of like look like spock acting like
spock
he was a good dude but uh
no i wouldn't say he wasn't a very
street wise kind of guy
um
but he's still kind he's still my
brother even though i i'd [ __ ] him up if
i saw him you know i mean just i'd have
to [ __ ] make fun of him but
over some of the [ __ ] that he believes
in but i'm telling you we had this time
me and me and [ __ ]
me and jason all right
granters probably remembers what the
name of this place was it was a
it was a [ __ ]
video game arcade
over there near taylor it looked like a
[ __ ] barn downtown it was it looked
like a barn it was shaped like a barn
kind had neon signs all around it
it was near where
there was a big blockbuster there that
we used to [ __ ]
rent movies from sometime
and then big haired [ __ ]
bon jovi looking
fringe jacket wearing taylor billy
chicks and [ __ ] pull up
in those old 1970s cars and [ __ ] going
hey man
you know trying to get faygo from you
and [ __ ]
china yeah trying to get famous from you
and
trying to get you to buy them some
southern comfort you know because they
were [ __ ] underage and you know they
were trying to trying to get booze off
you and [ __ ]
they called them taylor billies
but we used to go up to that arcade
and you might remember the name of that
arcade
there was a game in there
that me and jason quinlan [ __ ] we had
vowed we did this [ __ ] on a handshake
and everything we had vowed to beat that
[ __ ] game it kept whipping our asses
it was called akari warriors
okay
i ended up finding akari warriors play
through on youtube and it was just
brought me back okay
it was a game
two players you [ __ ] played it side
by side you had a joystick and two
buttons and the joystick had a knob that
you could rotate 360 degrees and you
controlled a little rambo
one guy had a rambo that was a [ __ ]
blue rambo and the other one had a red
rambo
what they were wearing i think it was
their head their shirts no they didn't
have shirts that's right they were
shirtless rambos i was gonna say
it was just um their headbands were
colored all right
and when you wrote you could move them
around and then you rotated the [ __ ]
joystick the knob on the stick to get
his gun to point in these different
directions
and you can either shoot your gun or
throw grenades
and you're fighting these aliens
and you could pick up all these
different kinds of guns and if you
picked up three of the same gun in a row
your gun got powered up each time
and you could throw regular grenades or
red grenades all these different kinds
of grenades you can pick up
and man [ __ ]
this thing was [ __ ] us up it was
you're fighting these aliens and one of
the main aliens that used to [ __ ] with
us we called them zimbubies
okay
and the zimwibe looked like a cross
between a little baby
and a [ __ ] teddy bear and they were
green and they'd come running at you
like millions of them
and when you [ __ ] hurt them or set
them on fire they go
so we called them zimbabwes all right
and [ __ ] we were fighting seas of
them and you had to have the flame
throwers you had to have flamethrowers
totally powered up to get those things
and then you're attacked by stone heads
a big head would look like a stone head
a skull with tentacles on it and it's
throwing [ __ ]
and and you just gotta fight your way
through this [ __ ]
weird
lsd inspired universe
rambo versus these [ __ ] monsters
and i think for us to get through that
game we had to spend 20 dollars and
quarters a piece
and when we finally won it we were just
it's like it's like we fought a real war
and we thought that was some serious
[ __ ] and when you're a teenager twenty
dollars especially back in those days
was a lot of that's a lot of money it's
a lot of money
twenty dollars a piece to get through
that thing i think
if i remember correctly twenty dollars
is still a lot of we're sitting there
[ __ ] we had to hold it go get some
coins go ahead get some coins we had to
get the tokens go get some tokens you
had to hold the game so nobody has to
get on it during the continue okay look
[ __ ] it i'm going to get some more coins
you know that shit's on the continue
countdown
well i watched the playthrough and i was
like that's all it was
it's like
it didn't suck it's just that it was
nowhere near as long as i thought it was
yeah it was like uh when you watch the
whole playthrough on youtube
i think it's about 35 minutes but it
seemed to take hours
yeah
when you're paying and just dumping
coins in it over and over again 35 or 40
minutes seems to take [ __ ] forever
and i think we spent like [ __ ] 20
bucks a piece or something because you
it gets so [ __ ] hard you're just
instantly annihilated you just you you
dude just keeps dying dying dying
it's like god damn it yeah grandpa said
it's called the red barn arcade red barn
arcade there well you should have it you
even said it wasn't like a big barn you
should it was right
it was right there yeah kanavatsan said
uh body of brighton rock from 2019 is a
good movie uh we actually uh talked
about that yeah because we saw it we did
a matinee on it i think
uh i'm pretty sure
uh wait a minute uh danny rowling said
growing up in the area of arcades would
have been cool it was pretty cool
actually the era of arcades yeah yeah it
was yeah they were
they were kind of like uh bars for
teenagers of that era
you could go down there and uh
run into other guys that were your age
that were into the same games
which that may or may not end up well
some dudes you know might fight or
or you might be oh yeah yeah you know
during that era another one that was
actually looked a lot better in terms of
graphics it was hard as [ __ ]
was blasteroids
it's like asteroids but you could two
guys could play it at once and they
could could join into a single ship
where one guy was flying and another guy
was controlling a turret on it and had
all the damn asteroids that was a real
good one we loved that one
um
another one from that era was [ __ ]
space harrier where you're a dude
running who could fly like with a jet
pack and he's got a gun he's fighting
all kinds of weird [ __ ] like that the
heads from eastern ireland are coming at
you and everything stardust yeah it's
like somebody damn zardoz
that was a good one too
yeah
grandpa said whatever happened to
jason's girlfriend
which one tracy
um somebody sent me a picture of her
unrecognizable
unrecognizable
she got married
and uh
man
i ain't gonna say nothing man i ain't
saying nothing i can't remember who that
was i think that was i think i brought
her up
to to steve and i think it was steve
that sent me a let he found her and sent
me a link to her and i was like i just
couldn't believe it that's gonna believe
it
she went crazy
they put her into an institution for a
little while
it was she had schizophrenia
[ __ ] that sucks yeah it wasn't her fault
but uh no time was not kind to her
but there were some of those girls
[ __ ]
mary lynn still looks great
you know and she i follow her on
instagram with her show she's still
doing shows mary we're talking about
marilyn ricegood
mary lynn still looks great
uh christy watson still looks great last
sr
uh
jody spears still looked uh good last
time i saw her um
a lot of those girls still look cute
um you know but they're they're moms now
you know just a different they're living
a different kind of life
there was one man i'm trying to remember
what her name was
she dropped out
she was cute back in the day she was uh
she was bill oligar's girlfriend you
remember him that punk rock guy
they were she dropped out and vanished
but somehow or another ran into her
again on facebook
i think through gene patrowski
and she hadn't changed the day she's got
full sleeves
cute as hell
our age you know and uh a bunch of kids
and married uh
like a corporate type dude and
like a trophy wife like a like a goth
like a goth trophy wife
at the age of 50. yeah look like a porn
star or something which i remember what
her name was though you probably
remember who he probably bill olinger's
ex-girlfriend
she dropped out
she left it like uh
i think she dropped out in the 11th
grade she's like she's like i can't take
these people these people [ __ ] suck
she left
you you might remember her name
grandpa said heidi still looks good and
then says yeah he's cute jody's dad
passed away a few days ago oh you saw
his name at the martinson's funeral home
today
yeah jody was a texan she was a cute
girl cute girl her brother was a real
thug but he tried to maybe drank all
that
drank all that down brake fluid when he
was in high school tried to kill himself
but he he snapped out of it i remember
him there seems to be better ways of
killing yourself than drinking
fluid i mean you know i mean i guess
that's what's available you might
remember
bill ollinger zack's i don't remember
what her name was
been a while i think it started with the
b
first name john gore says the designers
those old arcade games were probably an
interesting lot they are they are yeah
well didn't they do
um what's their series on netflix called
game over or something like that that
was kind of all about that
i think it was a series i remember that
being good
there was another one during that same
time me and me and um
jason were [ __ ] just
we had a damn blood oath a pact to to
[ __ ]
beat akari warriors
during that same time they had one
called narcs or narcos yeah kind of
aslan just brought that up narcs don't
forget the game narcissist yeah yeah no
okay yeah i didn't see that narcs yeah
we were trying to beat that one too
that one was [ __ ] bizarre that was
80s as [ __ ] it was about the crack
epidemic
and angel dust and it's you're like
these cops fighting [ __ ] drugged out
people who were picking up [ __ ]
big ass [ __ ] dumpsters and throwing
them at you and [ __ ]
people that had been mutated into
monsters and it was that games was 80s
as [ __ ]
but it looked good the graphics were
real good for the time
and then there were some of them that
were gang fighting
i don't remember the name of it though
the whole streets of rage that's what it
was called you had to go out there
[ __ ] fight dudes with their fists
that was 80s as [ __ ]
yeah streets of rage yeah
that's hilarious because i kind of feel
like that was so prevalent in these
movies
like you had all without sleeves they
had all these gangs and they all had
like coordinated costumes yeah like that
they'd all do like these [ __ ] yeah it
was like west sides yeah yeah
except west side story is actually good
yeah uh sly says tom i did not start
sinking until i hit 69 years old yeah
get on test
that's what he tells everybody yeah get
all tests you'll be fine
just inject a bunch of it
john gore says i knew someone who
guzzled clorox didn't work nah
why would you want to do that like i
said i mean
grantham said i don't remember bill's ex
just remember she was a hot punk chick
yeah real hot punk chick
i don't remember her name
well neither does he
bill olinger and uh little what's his
name the other punk rock guy
do you remember little what's his name
yeah he was cool too but
i couldn't hang out with him nobody
could hang out with him he was so
anti-social he wouldn't hang out with
anybody even if he liked you
he sat next to me and [ __ ] one of my
classes of [ __ ] [ __ ]
i kind of became friends with him and he
still wouldn't let me hang out with him
and i remember that bitch's name was he
was [ __ ] funny as [ __ ] had a mohawk
and [ __ ] combat boots and a leather
jacket and [ __ ] it kind of was like a
and
even girl girls liked him and he
wouldn't even go out he wouldn't even
[ __ ] date girls
well he was just really interested i
remember his name some people just don't
like hanging out yeah
[Laughter]
it's okay
yeah
he knows who he is
well i would hope so i think most people
know who they are no
i know i'm just teasing
it's just the way you said that yeah he
knows it's really funny it's all about
grampa's scranton's know who knows who
he is oh sly said drinking he meant he
didn't start drinking until he was 69.
oh okay
bill bill
was was a real cool punk rock dude who's
about six feet tall he was handsome and
blonde and [ __ ] he knew how to dress
and [ __ ] he was like the ken doll of
all the [ __ ] punk rock goth girls
they all they [ __ ] loved that dude
and he kind of just kind of vanished he
vanished off with girls never saw that
[ __ ] again once he got a girlfriend he
was advantaged i'm not even sure he
graduated
i wasn't i wasn't at trenton high
for graduation time i graduated in
brazil i went back to brazil
but uh
yeah but bill we you know
steve liked bill too but bill was
[ __ ] so wrapped up
with those punk rock girls he would
never hang out with guys
he didn't have time
that's you know i don't have time he'd
have time to hang out with guys i think
[ __ ] yeah
i respected his game
i've got ladies respecting his game
sorry guys man [ __ ] i can't hang out i
gotta go
grandfather said bill is an english high
school teacher in connecticut now oh is
he okay
and there you go
next dimension media says i had a
commodore 64. yeah and bought a book
where you program games using basic oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] i remember doing that in
school yeah old man voice back in my day
if you wanted to play video games you
had to code it yourself yeah well yeah
sometimes you did commodore 64 had good
games though that you could buy some of
them i remember them remember i remember
my friend had one
up in brazil he had a commodore 64. he
was an american guy who brought it
through brought it through with him
through customs
and uh he had some games for it and i
remember that they were good at least
for the time but they were much better
than atari 2600 because that's what it
was up against at the time
another good system was [ __ ]
i wouldn't even mind owning one
okay was apple ii
and the [ __ ] the main game we used to
play on that was wizardry 2. oh i
remember that yeah i loved wizardry too
although there's probably nothing to it
today but i would own i would own that
system just to play wizardry on it like
back in the day
it just had a certain feel to that game
i remember them starting when i was in
third grade i remember them teaching us
basic
and we had to like
learn to program [ __ ] like that those
big ass [ __ ]
floppy disks yeah we did like we we had
to code like mad libs games and
[ __ ] like that i remember all that kind
of stuff that was a long time ago
sly says uh jenny and tom did you guys
ever watch uh the family tv series
1976-1989
i don't think so it sounds like familiar
but i don't remember if i ever watched
it
john gore said hanging out with the guys
always led to trouble just senseless
hell raising
yeah well
but that was part of the that was part
of the deal man we had [ __ ] a lot of
fun and we were
we were all [ __ ] getting lots of
girlfriends you know at least me and
steve were jason got some
uh mike didn't get a whole lot of
girlfriends he wasn't real real um
confident with with women that were in
high school
he actually
at that time when he was in high school
we're going for women that were out of
high school and had kids for some reason
he was into this he was into this single
mom thing he likes the milfs yeah meals
but they weren't old you know what i
mean they were they were only like a
year well i mean people say milf like
that but i mean milf that doesn't
necessarily imply that they're old as
they just have kids yeah [ __ ]
but uh mike
he he kind of had a confidence problem
when he was in high school
but now he's [ __ ] uh he's a stud
he ended up uh
getting involved in [ __ ] forensics
and law enforcement he
i was his his best friend you know and
he saw me go into the military and
change some and he tried to go in the
military he didn't make it
he washed out he was real embarrassed to
buy that
he went back home and started getting
into the uh paramedics
and excelled he ended up becoming owning
his own paramedic company
and then he and owns his own forensic
company working for the police as a
contractor he cleans up crime scenes
there's i've heard there's a lot of
money yeah actually yeah so mike's a
[ __ ] hardened veteran
of of of law enforcement now in terms of
in the support
um
thing now michael was always skinny
and kind of gangly looking when he was a
kid
man he's a good looking dude now he's
[ __ ] buffed out he looks like um the
dude from [ __ ] dead zone what's his
name oh
who christopher walken no the other guy
oh that guy oh the tv series the tv
series yeah anthony michael hall anthony
michael hall he looked like anthony
michael hall when he was a kid and he
looked like anthony michael hall when
anthony michael hall became in his
[ __ ] 30s or 40s he that same kind of
transformation you wouldn't recognize
him if you saw him today
but he used to get [ __ ]
made fun of in high school you know and
uh
i felt bad for him because he was a good
dude you know grandpa's kind of test he
was just kind of a skinny
guy and he kind of
didn't look real comfortable with
himself he was though it's just it was
the way he looked i mean people treat
you a certain way based on your look
they respond to you on how you look
but he became a stud your hot wife and
[ __ ] bunch of kids and [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
business a lot of money you know just
you can't you can't predict what's going
to happen to some dude just by the way
he looked in high school
well yeah because sometimes people
change a lot they change a lot yeah you
know sometimes they don't
but
yeah but he looks like my anthony
michael hall now
yeah not like anthony michael hall in
the breakfast right yeah he looks like
he alcohol in the breakfast club yeah
[ __ ] grandpa's nose he'll tell you
uh
let me see
all right so we've been going almost
three hours yeah you ready you're
getting kind of tired i'm getting i'm
kind of tired and i'm kind of hungry
yeah we'll get something i kind of want
to watch that mad god movie
before it gets too late so i don't fall
asleep yeah because sly is talking about
recycling
yeah
but the thing is with him is i think
they wanted to recycle him but he wasn't
in the army he was in the navy they
wanted to recycle him in the navy and i
think he quit so then they got rid of
him and he was kind of embarrassed of
that so he came back to civilian world
and uh
got into the law enforcement support
thing and i was telling you about how
i was a huge eddie murphy fan you know
with with um
beverly hills cop
well
mike the dude i'm telling you about he
was right along with me [ __ ] we would
you know
watch beverly hills cop and [ __ ] you
know and do the whole [ __ ] eddie
murphy routines and
and really he wanted to be
he wanted to be [ __ ] axel foley he
did
and that that movie
and that's and he became that basically
in a way not the cop but you know uh
a guy who owned a company who
supported law enforcement and that was
really eddie murphy it did that to him
so it's just weird how how life works
that
life imitates art
you know well yeah if you get likes
we're particularly inspired by something
yeah yeah there's cool actually yeah
danny rowling said tom cevini did a
great job as the creeper in the creep
show series yeah that's right just
saying need more of that character yeah
yeah i kind of well wasn't he in they
put him in creep show 2
which is still like an okay movie but i
didn't really like the animated segments
i wish they would have done like the
puppet you know what i mean like they
did on the first one
but
kanabazon says jenny the series la
revolucion is on netflix it's french
with subtitles and good okay well i have
to check that out uh we'll have to check
that out
then
watch used cars instead yeah
we will eventually but i did kind of
want to see that shutter movie because
yeah because like i said a bunch of
people have like recommended that to me
so all right so we will be back uh
tomorrow
right yeah talking about the last duel
the ridley scott movie yeah because
that's the one and the good movie you
guys haven't seen go see it yeah wait so
like i said dermot uh sign us money you
got it so we watched it another night so
we'll be talking about that tomorrow so
hopefully you guys have a good weekend
up until we see you again we will see
you guys again
tomorrow evening thanks for hanging out
with us on this saturday night
good night